Hey guys, happy smartless.
We're going to smartless the hell out of this.
We're going to really podcast it up today.
I hope you're ready.
Put your helmet on.
Clean your ears because it's coming in.
Welcome to smartless.
Late afternoon, late afternoon podcast.
大家好，欢迎收听 SmartLess。我们要把这个节目做大做强。今天我们要好好录个播客。希望你们准备好了。戴上头盔。洗好耳朵，因为节目要开始了。欢迎来到 SmartLess。下午好，下午好播客。
Well, let's just start up saying, happy birthday to Will.
Hey, happy birthday, Will.
Oh, my goodness.
It's so crazy on my birthday today.
This finally, I was finally able to shit this out.
I had this.
Lucky horseshoe?
This horseshoe up my ass the whole time.
好吧，我们先祝威尔生日快乐。嘿，生日快乐，威尔。哦，天哪。今天我过生日，感觉太疯狂了。我终于，我终于能把这事儿痛快地说出来了。我有这个。幸运马蹄铁？这马蹄铁一直塞在我屁股里。
That explains a lot in your life.
Yeah.
Now what happens now that it's out of your ass?
Does that mean it's all downhill?
No, I'm going to put it right back where it came from.
I mean, the horse is still up there.
Shawnee.
Will?
这能解释你生活中的很多事。对啊。现在它从你屁股里出来后，会发生什么？是不是意味着一切都在走下坡路？不，我要把它塞回它原来的地方。我是说，那匹马还在那儿呢。肖妮。威尔？
Your little devil.
Did you get anything enjoyable for your birthday?
Did your boys take good care of you?
What happened?
I got a nice.
I got a nice candle from J.B. and Amanda.
Oh, that's nice.
With a beautiful card.
你这个小淘气。你生日收到什么喜欢的礼物了吗？你儿子们把你照顾得怎么样？发生什么了？我收到了一份不错的。我收到了一根 J.B. 和阿曼达送的精美蜡烛。哦，那挺好。还有一张漂亮的卡片。
I could tell.
I could tell by the candle that J.B. had picked it.
Yeah, exactly.
You know me.
I like my candles and my soaps.
And that candle right there from Jenny Kane is just about the tip is topiest.
It's a two-wick candle.
You know, three-wick, you can't really control the burn.
我看得出来。我从那根蜡烛就看得出来是 J.B. 选的。对，没错。你了解我。我喜欢我的蜡烛和香皂。珍妮·凯恩（Jenny Kane）的那根蜡烛简直是顶级中的顶级。这是一根双芯蜡烛。你知道的，三芯的蜡烛，你很难控制它的燃烧。
You know, you're going to have a side that doesn't really keep up with the other side.
You're going to get a weak side.
You're going to get a weak side on a three-week burn.
The wax is going to flood the other one and then you're screwed.
But with a two-wick-wit.
It's a metaphor for us.
I'm a two-wick-burn kind of guy.
Yeah, sure.
你知道的，你会有一边跟不上另一边。你会有一边燃烧不均匀。三芯蜡烛燃烧时会有一边比较弱。蜡会把另一边淹没，然后你就完蛋了。但双芯的就不一样了。这简直是我们的隐喻。我是那种双芯燃烧的男人。对，确实。
So I got that.
I got a nice sort of self-care thing from Shawnee,
a little gifts or tiff.
Are you going to, now don't, a lot of people just like.
A G-s or tiff.
They let the treatments expire.
You know, they forget they've got them.
No, not this one.
所以我收到了那个。我还收到了肖妮送的一份很好的自我关怀护理，一个小礼物或什么。你打算，先别，很多人只是。一个小礼物。他们让护理项目过期了。你知道的，他们忘了自己有这东西。不，这个可不会。
You've got to get in there.
By the way, I had to take out a loan for this one.
Yeah.
Oh.
Huh, you once gave me a self-care thing and it was quite panic.
Oh, is it the same?
No.
No, this is a new one.
你得抓紧去享受。顺便说一句，为了这个我不得不贷个款。呀。哦。哼，你以前也送过我一次自我关怀护理，那可真是让人惊恐。哦，是同一个吗？不是。不，这是个新的。
I'll get you with, I'll get you this one too, Jay.
You damn right, you will.
This is tough.
We can't even go broadcast on this one.
It's so.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She just comes right over to the house and, um.
我也会送你这个的，杰伊。你说得对，你会的。这太难了。我们甚至都没法在节目里播这个。太……真的吗？对，对，对。她直接来家里，然后……
No, but you will, let me just say you will not complain.
I will not what?
Complain.
Well, that's not true.
No?
We never know about you.
Yeah, you know I like to squeak.
He's a real squeaky wheel.
不，不过我要说的是，你绝对不会抱怨。我不会什么？抱怨。好吧，那可不一定。不是吗？我们可说不准你。对，你知道我喜欢发牢骚。他真是个爱抱怨的家伙。
And then, Danny and Doddy D's gave me some nice books.
Oh, that's nice.
Yeah.
That you're going to read.
One said you.
Now, do your boys panic about what to get the guy who's got it all?
Or do they know what they're doing?
No, I tell them not to get me anything.
然后，丹尼和多迪·D 给我买了一些好书。哦，那挺好。对。你会去读的。其中一本说你。现在，你的儿子们会为给一个应有尽有的男人买什么礼物而感到恐慌吗？还是他们知道自己在做什么？不，我告诉他们什么都别买。
I just want to hang out.
So I got to have them.
I'm the same.
Yeah, because I don't want people stressing about buying me something.
I don't want anything.
I know, but people like to do it.
I mean, we have this conversation.
ad nausea.
我只想一起聚聚。所以我让他们。我也是。对，因为我不想让别人为给我买礼物而感到压力。我什么都不想要。我知道，但人们就是喜欢这样做。我是说，我们已经讨论过这个问题无数次了。
Right, but as long as you say no gifts, please,
then at least it takes the pressure off.
Yeah.
Yeah, but I always ignore that.
I don't know, I learned at such an early age,
you always show up with,
even if you just go over somebody's house to visit,
you always show up with something.
对，但只要你说了请不要送礼物，那至少能减轻压力。对。对，但我总是忽视这一点。我不知道，我从小就懂这个道理，你去看望别人时总是会带点东西，哪怕只是去串门，你也总会带点什么。
Yeah.
Uh-oh, you guys still there?
Well, yeah, I'm just thinking about all the sweet treats
you've always brought over.
You know, you're never without at least a cookie.
Right.
Either for myself or for others.
Yep.
对。呃-哦，你们还在吗？好吧，对，我只是在想你以前带过来的那些甜点。你知道的，你什么时候去都不会少了一块曲奇饼。对的。要么留给我自己，要么给别人。没错。
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
I brought you this.
Don't touch it.
Yeah.
We had a great cake last night.
Oh, my God, that cake.
I saw the photo.
嗯哼。对。我给你带了这个。别碰它。对。我们昨晚吃了一个超棒的蛋糕。哦，天哪，那个蛋糕。我看到照片了。
I was waiting for the guy to come out to say,
do you want another piece?
I know, I know.
Like, nobody came out for a second piece.
The guy.
They only cut up half of it.
Waiting for the guy.
Were you waiting for Jen to say,
我当时在等那个切蛋糕的人出来问：“还要来一块吗？”我知道，我知道。真的，没人出来问要不要第二块。那个切蛋糕的人。他们只切了一半。在等那个人。你是不是在等简（Jen）说，
can you have another piece?
Yeah, or somebody.
I was like...
Did they know?
No, what type of cake was it?
It wasn't the Rice Krispy one I was it?
No, no.
It was a classic, it was a classic Duncan Hines...
你能再吃一块吗？对，或者随便谁。我当时就想……他们知道吗？不，那是什么类型的蛋糕？不是我说的那个脆米饼蛋糕吧？不是，不是。是个经典款，是个经典的邓肯·海恩斯（Duncan Hines）……
yellow cake with chocolate frosting.
But done in the way, it was box worthy.
Did you bring your own hot fudge, you fucking shit pig?
No, it's not.
That's your move.
By the way, last year of my birthday, you remember,
and I brought some kind of like better scour or something,
and for the Sundays.
黄蛋糕配巧克力糖霜。但做出来的那种感觉，简直配得上拍成广告。你他妈这个狗屎猪，是不是自己带了热fudge酱来？不，不是。那是你的招牌动作。顺便说一句，去年我过生日，你还记得吧，我带了某种类似冰淇淋果仁酱之类配圣代的东西。
To the restaurants.
To the restaurant.
Where do you think this bit's coming from?
To Tower Bar.
And so then everybody's giving me shit,
and then Camel is giving me so much shit.
And then the ice cream comes out,
and everybody's like, hey, can you pass that?
带到了餐馆。带到了餐馆。你觉得这个段子是从哪来的？带到了塔楼酒吧（Tower Bar）。然后大家都在损我，凯梅尔（Camel）也把我损得够呛。然后冰淇淋端上来了，大家都说，嘿，能把那个递一下吗？
Hey, can you pass that?
No, it was caramel.
Carmel.
Everybody used it, J.
It was hilarious.
Now, last night, when you had that...
First of all, what flavor is yellow?
Vanilla.
嘿，能把那个递一下吗？不，那是焦糖酱。焦糖（Carmel）。每个人都用了，杰伊。太搞笑。话说昨晚，当你吃那个……首先，黄色是什么味道？香草。
Is it just vanilla?
Yeah, it's a rich vanilla.
All right, fine.
Like a French vanilla is usually kind of yellow.
Is it an angel food?
Is that what it is?
I don't know what it is.
What did you call me?
就只是香草吗？对，是浓郁的香草味。好吧，好吧。就像法式香草通常有点发黄那样。是天使蛋糕吗？是那个吗？我不知道那是什么。你刚叫我什么？
Angel.
But it was fun.
You were missed, J.B.
It was really fun.
Yeah, J.B., you were missed.
You were missed.
I miss being there, damn.
And it was cool.
天使。但真的很开心。大家都很想念你，J.B.。真的挺好玩的。对啊，J.B.，大家都很想念你。想念你在场的日子，该死。而且挺酷的。
We got the kids involved.
MAPE and Nable.
That was the best thing in the night.
Will starting to throw...
We'll start to throw...
We're talking about everything that's going on in the world.
No, what's going on in the world?
And I said, you know what?
我们把孩子们也牵扯进来了。枫树（Maple）和内布（Nable）。那是当晚最棒的部分。威尔开始抛出……威尔开始抛出……我们正在谈论世界上发生的一切。不，世界上正发生什么？然后我说，你知道吗？
And the kids were at the end.
Arts wasn't feeling well, but Ava and Maper were there.
And I said, what do you guys think about
what we're talking about
and all this stuff that's going on
and what all the grown-ups are talking about
right now in the world?
And are you guys stressed and blah, blah, blah.
孩子们当时就在旁边。阿尔茨（Arts）当时身体不太舒服，但艾娃（Ava）和枫树（Maple）都在。然后我说，你们对我们刚才聊的这些事、对世界上正在发生的事情、对大人们现在讨论的所有这些有什么看法？你们觉得有压力吗，巴拉巴拉的。
And they each...
And I say, open up the straight.
Isn't that what Maple said?
Let's just open the straight.
Just let the oil flow.
Yeah.
Dude, they both gave...
really good thoughtful answers that were really represented with it yeah it was so interesting to listen
然后他们每个……我说，敞开心扉吧。枫树不就是这么说的吗？我们就敞开天窗说亮话吧。让思绪自由流淌吧。对啊。老兄，他们俩都给出了……非常棒、很有深度的回答，真的很有代表性，对啊，听他们说真的太有趣了。
to them yeah it was wild to it was wild to look over to both of them who have known since they were
you know tiny yeah and have these incredible you know it was dope yeah incredible opinions thoughtful
you know thoughts they're both very bright yeah they really are uh tell you who's tell you who's
I tell you who's bright is our guest.
I am excited for our guest today, man.
This is, yeah, this is a dude that I have been such a fan of for a long, long time.
And he's done.
His number of credits are insane.
对啊，太疯狂了。看着他们两个，从他们还是（你知道的）小不点的时候就认识了，现在能有这些不可思议的……你知道的，这太酷了。对，有不可思议的观点、深思熟虑的（你知道的）想法，他们俩都非常聪明。对，他们真的很聪明。呃，告诉你谁是……告诉你谁是聪明人，我们的嘉宾。我为今天的嘉宾感到兴奋，伙计。这是一个我崇拜了很久很久的家伙。他拍过。他的作品数量简直疯狂。
Sean, you're going to like this, okay?
He studied at the prestigious Moscow Arts Theater in Russia, okay?
And then he went, I'm pretty sure he went to Harvard
and got a master of fine arts
or he did something like in there.
He's like studied like crazy theater
has done a ton of theater.
He's currently in the show in Broadway,
肖恩，你会喜欢这个的，好吗？他在俄罗斯著名的莫斯科艺术剧院（Moscow Art Theater）学习过，好吗？然后他去，我确信他去了哈佛并获得了艺术硕士学位，或者他大概在那里做过类似的事。他疯狂地学习过戏剧，演过大量的戏剧。他目前正在百老汇的一部剧里演出，
and I want to say the title of the show
because you're going to know who it is immediately.
He's done...
Adrian Brodie.
Countless...
Countless great performances in Wolf of Wall Street.
He was added as a small part in Sicario,
baby driver, Winn River,
我想说出这部剧的名字，因为你马上就会知道他是谁了。他演过……阿德里安·布洛迪。无数……《华尔街之狼》中无数精彩的表演。他在《边境杀手》（Sicario）、《极盗车神》（Baby Driver）、《猎凶风河谷》（Wind River）里客串过小角色，
and they had great parts in Ford versus Ferrari,
King Richard.
You also know him as the Punisher.
He's going to be in The Odyssey,
who's the accountant.
accountant two. He's been in, I got to know him by watching him on The Walking Dead,
but I loved him in this series. We Own the City, guys. It's John Bernthal. Yeah. The great.
Oh my gosh. I kind of got it. The great.
他们在《极速车王》（Ford v Ferrari）、《国王理查德》（King Richard）里都有出色的角色。你们也知道他是“惩罚者”。他将出演《奥德赛》，谁是那个会计师？会计师2。他演过，我是通过看《行尸走肉》认识他的，但我超级喜欢他在这个剧里的表现。我们拥有这座城市（We Own This City），伙计们。是乔·博恩瑟（John Bernthal）。对。太棒了。天哪。我差不多猜到了。太棒了。
Hell. Wow. Wow. Hey, buddy. John, what a thrill, man. I'm such a fan, dude. I'm such a fan of
what you do. Man, this is so cool. That's so cool. You just say a happy birthday, Will.
And I have to just. Sing it, John. Sing it. Man, I would sing it, but I'm trying to cheat. I'm trying to, I'm trying to,
you know, save my voice for Broadway right now.
Holy fuck.
Yeah.
But Will, man, I just, I want to tell you how much I just was blown away by, by your film, man.
Oh, yeah.
见鬼。哇。哇。嘿，老兄。约翰，太让人激动了，老兄。我是你的超级粉丝，老兄。我非常喜欢你的作品。天哪，太酷了。太酷了。你刚才说生日快乐，威尔。我不得不。唱一个，约翰。唱一个。老兄，我很想唱，但我在作弊。我正在，我正在，你知道的，为了百老汇的演出在保护我的嗓子。他妈的。对。但威尔，老兄，我只想告诉你，你的电影让我感到多么震撼，老兄。哦，对。
Like, just such a beautiful dive into, yeah, but just like about fatherhood and being a husband and being an artist and like re-falling in love with your wife.
And it just like, I don't know, it was one of those things where, you know, like I found it on like the perfect day and the perfect time.
And it just filled me with so much.
It really was your performance.
It was just so I reached out to Bradley about it as well,
but it was just such a human, gorgeous, deep, felt performance.
And it was awesome, man.
Thank you, man.
就像，对父职、作为丈夫、作为艺术家以及重新爱上妻子的极其美好的探讨。而且就好像，我不知道，这是那种你在完美的一天、完美的时刻碰巧找到的作品。它让我内心充满了充实感。真的是你的表演。它是如此的……我也就此联系了布拉德利（Bradley），这真的是一种非常人性化、极其华丽、深入内心的表演。太棒了，老兄。谢谢你，老兄。
Thank you very kindly.
Thank you, dude.
And I know you mentioned that you're saving your voice.
John is currently, as you guys know, in Dog Day Afternoon on Broadway.
Big hit.
With my good buddy, Johnny O is in that, too.
Oh, yeah, the best.
The best.
非常感谢。谢谢你，老兄。我知道你提到你在保护嗓子。如大家所知，约翰目前正在百老汇出演《热天午后》（Dog Day Afternoon）。大获成功。我的好哥们儿约翰尼·O（Johnny O）也在里面。哦，对，最棒的。最棒的。
Johnny O.
And, I mean, how's that going, man?
How's the play going?
I mean, it's a hit, as Sean said.
I mean, look, it's been, it's so cool that folks are coming to the theater that don't normally come to the theater.
I love seeing that.
It's so many people that we see outside say it's the first time, not just that they've ever been on Broadway, but that they're coming to the theater.
Like buses are coming in from Staten Island, which is so great.
约翰尼·O。而且，我的意思是，进展如何，老兄？这出戏演得怎么样？我的意思是，正如肖恩所说，它是个大热剧。我的意思是，听着，最酷的是，平时不怎么看戏剧的人们现在都走进剧场了。我很高兴看到这一点。我们在外面看到的很多人都说，这不仅是他们第一次来百老汇，甚至是他们第一次走进剧场。甚至有史丹顿岛开来的大巴车，这太棒了。
And, yeah, I mean, not to be a total cheese dick, but I did.
I kind of, this thing, you know, sort of saved my life.
And I kind of came about it in Russia.
That's really where I figured this, you know, that's really where my formative years were.
And, you know, theater there is very vital.
And it's for everybody.
It's not this sort of exclusive thing for the gentry.
It's for everybody.
而且，好吧，虽然听起来可能有点肉麻，但我的确。某种程度上，这件事（你知道的）算是拯救了我的生命。我是在俄罗斯接触到这一点的。那真的是我摸索出这一点的（你知道的），那真的是我形成世界观的岁月。而且，那里的戏剧非常充满活力。它是属于所有人的。它不是那种专属于上流社会的排他性东西。它是属于所有人的。
And it's a part of everyday life.
And it's enormously important to folks.
So it's really cool.
I think that this is just sort of expanding the theater audience.
It's been a thrill.
It's been a thrill to see how much people dig it.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, you mentioned it, I mentioned, too, that you don't, that you, that you, that
它是日常生活的一部分。对人们来说极其重要。所以这真的很酷。我认为这只是在扩大戏剧观众群体。看到大家这么喜欢它，真的很让人激动。真的。对，我的意思是，你提到了，我也提到了，你没有，你没有，你曾……
you studied in Russia, and I'm kind of so interested because you grew up in Maryland,
which I want to get, we're going to come back to Maryland because we're going to come back
to, we own this city because, dude.
Okay.
But you ended up studying theater in Russia.
I'm like, how, walk us through how that happened, man, because that's extraordinary.
It seems like, well, yeah, and what time was that about what year was that?
So I lived in Russia from 1990.
你在俄罗斯学习过，我对此非常感兴趣，因为你在马里兰州长大，我想，我们要回到马里兰州的话题，因为我们要聊回《我们拥有这座城市》，因为，老兄。好吧。但你最终却去俄罗斯学习戏剧。我在想，怎么回事，带我们回顾一下这是怎么发生的，老兄，因为这太非同寻常了。感觉就像，好吧，是的，那是大概什么时候，大约是哪一年？所以我从1990年住在俄罗斯。
to I guess 2001 and and and honestly I mean it's something you know I went to school to play sports
I played football and baseball and played baseball in in college and um but I was getting in all kinds of
trouble and really if there was if there was a dead end to walk down I was walking down and just
running into every kind of wall and um you know I really sort of found theater on on an accident
I was just an idiot and I signed up for a class and I thought I was
taking the class with 600 kids in it and sitting in the back of the theater watching movies,
but me being the kind of asshole that I was, I signed up for the, you know, the intro to theater
class, which was just 10 people, took it very seriously.
一直住到2001年左右，说实话，你知道的，我上学是为了玩体育，我踢过橄榄球和棒球，在大学里打过棒球，而且，呃，但我总是惹上各种各样的麻烦，真的，如果有一条死胡同可以走，我一定在走，而且会撞到每一堵墙上，呃，你知道的，我真的是机缘巧合才接触到戏剧的，我当时就是个白痴，我选修了一门课，我以为这门课有600个学生一起上，大家坐在剧院后面看电影，但我偏偏是个混蛋，我选修的那门戏剧概论课，其实只有10个人，却被我很严肃地对待了。
You thought it was like a movie theater?
I totally did, man.
That's what I heard.
All the athletes were like, you have to take an art requirement, and I had no idea.
And, you know, I've told this story before, but the first assignment was to bring in something
that was deeply important to you and to share it with the class.
and I had never seen such weird.
I'd never experienced something,
你以为那是电影院？我完全是这么想的，老兄。我听到的就是这样。所有运动员都说，你必须修一门艺术学分，而我一无所知。而且，你知道的，我以前讲过这个故事，但第一个作业是带一件对你意义重大的东西来，并在课堂上与大家分享。我从来没见过这么诡异的事。我从来没经历过这种事，
this sort of insane of these grown people
talking about an object that that was so important to them
and emoting and breaking down.
I'd never really been around theater people before
and slowly but surely it came to my turn
and I didn't bring anything.
I didn't have anything because I was such a donkey.
And, you know, but I was going to fall baseball practice right after
这些成年人谈论着一个对他们如此重要、充满情绪波动和崩溃的物件，这种疯狂的程度我从没见过。我以前从没和戏剧圈的人接触过，慢慢地，终于轮到我了。我什么都没带。我什么都没有，因为我就是个大笨蛋。而且，你知道的，我马上要去参加棒球训练，
and I had my catchers club with me.
So I just launched into it.
to this story about how my mother had given me this baseball glove on her deathbed.
And my mom's like alive and well in D.C., but I launched into this story and I'm crying my eyes
out.
And everyone in the room is crying their eyes out.
I'm like, no, no, no, wait, wait, wait.
I'm doing the acting, you know?
我随身带着捕手手套。所以我顺理成章地编造了这样一个故事：我母亲在临终前把这副棒球手套送给了我。我妈在华盛顿特区活得好好的，但我却声泪俱下地开始讲这个故事。屋里的每个人都在哭。我说，不，不，不，等等，等等。我在演戏呢，你知道吗？
And like, snop was coming out of my, I was just so upset because I got lost in the story.
And so this wonderful woman, Alma Becker, who my first theater teacher ended up marrying my wife
and I.
she kicked everybody out of that class
and she just ripped my ass for violating
the sanctity of her studio.
But she's like, you know, you got something.
And my punishment was to audition for the play.
而且鼻涕都从我鼻子里喷出来了，我当时太难过了，因为我完全沉浸在故事里了。于是这位了不起的女士，我的第一位戏剧老师阿尔玛·贝克尔（Alma Becker）——后来还为我和我妻子主持了婚礼——她把所有人赶出了教室，把我狠狠骂了一顿，因为我亵渎了她工作室的神圣性。但她说，你知道的，你身上有点东西。而对我的惩罚，就是去试镜一出话剧。
And I got into it and I did the play.
And she was the one when I wound up getting
in a little bit of trouble and I couldn't finish school.
You know, I said, look, this is something I really wanted to do.
And I had no idea sort of what the pathway was.
And she said, look, there is none.
But if I were you, I would try to get into the Moscow Art Theater.
and go study over there.
我通过了试镜，演了那出话剧。后来当我惹上了一点麻烦、无法完成学业时，正是她对我说：“听着，这是你真正想做的事。”我当时根本不知道未来的道路在哪里。她说：“听着，根本没有什么所谓的道路。但如果我是你，我会试着考进莫斯科艺术剧院，去那里深造。”
That's amazing.
Yeah, to save my life.
I mean, and being in Russia.
Yeah, but what part of that for, I mean, I'll show my ignorance here because I'll bet the Moscow.
Again?
Yeah, that school is a clear pathway to stuff.
But what you didn't know that, why would you think that that would be, oh, yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
I'll go to Moscow to figure out how to break into, you know,
太惊人了。对，这救了我的命。我是说，身处俄罗斯。对，但其中一部分，我是说，在这里我要显露我的无知了，因为我敢打赌莫斯科……又来了？对，那所学校是通往成功的明确途径。但你当时并不知道这一点，你为什么会觉得那会是……哦，对，这太合理了。我要去莫斯科摸索怎么打入，你知道的，
New York or Hollywood.
Yeah, I wasn't really thinking about kind of, you know,
breaking in wasn't really even in the, you know, like staying out of trouble
and just just finding this thing.
And really just this sort of blind faith I had in this wonderful woman.
And it's just such a testament to how beautiful a teacher,
you know, the role that they can have in a young person's life.
And it's just astounding.
纽约或好莱坞。对，我当时根本没想过什么“打入”，这甚至都不在……你知道的，当时只想远离麻烦，只是想找到这个东西。真的只是我对这位了不起的女士有着那种盲目的信任。这也充分证明了一位优秀的老师在年轻人生命中所扮演的角色是多么美好，简直太惊人了。
She saved my life.
And I, and it's really cool being here in New York and being on Broadway
because I do feel so much of, I'm very, I feel like I'm very in touch with that 18 year old kid,
with that kid who found this thing and would have never believed in a million years,
you would have the opportunity to go out there, you know, in front of this kind of audience every day.
And Alma is very much with me.
You know, we lost her a few years back way too young.
But I think I just had blind faith in her, and it wasn't really a pathway to New York.
她救了我的命。而且，现在身在纽约并登上百老汇的舞台感觉真的很酷，因为我真的觉得，我与那个18岁的孩子、那个发现了这个东西、并且做梦也想不到有朝一日有机会每天在那种观众面前演出的孩子有着极深的联系。阿尔玛一直都在我身边。你知道的，几年前我们失去了她，她走得太早了。但我对她有着盲目的信任，这其实并不是通往纽约的捷径。
I didn't know what an agent was.
But it was that school, that place.
Wow.
Did you lie?
I mean, like, I'm an idiot.
Like, my perception of going to Russia now, I would never step foot in Russia just because
of the, you know, I watched the news.
You might not come back.
我当时甚至不知道什么是经纪人。但那就是那所学校，那个地方。哇。你撒谎了吗？我是说，就像，我像个白痴。现在我对去俄罗斯的看法是，仅仅因为……你知道的，我看新闻，我绝对不会踏足俄罗斯半步。你可能就回不去了。
I might not come back.
What was it like for you then?
And what is it?
And would you ever go back?
Oh, I would love to go back.
This was, what, 15, 20 years ago?
Yeah, I mean, now you can't.
It was 99.
我可能就回不去了。你当时觉得那里怎么样？现在呢？你还会想回去吗？哦，我很想回去。那是，什么，15、20年前的事了？对啊，现在可去不了了。那是99年。
So, you know, that's when I first went.
I mean, it was a wild time.
You know, people referred to it as the Wild West there, you know.
There were shootings at the Duma, which is like their Senate.
You know, the Chechens were blowing up apartment buildings in town.
Wow.
It was completely wild.
People were really, it was still at the beginning of this.
所以，你知道的，那是我第一次去。那真是一个疯狂的时代。你知道的，人们把那里称为“狂野西部”。杜马（也就是他们的参议院）外面甚至会有枪击事件。你知道的，车臣人在城里炸毁公寓楼。哇。简直完全是狂野的。人们真的，那还只是这一切的开始。
And you're like, and I have a curtain at 8 p.m. people.
I got to get through the streets.
Yeah.
But I do think, you know, for me, you know, a few things at play.
I mean, I think I sort of considered myself at the time.
You know, I was a boxer.
I was sort of a, you know, considered myself a street smart kind of guy.
So to kind of go into a world where not just it's a different alphabet,
而你会想，我晚上8点还有场演出呢，各位。我还得穿过街道呢。对，但我确实认为，对当时的我和几件事而言……我是说，我觉得自己当时……我是一个拳击手。我某种程度上认为自己是一个街头精明的家伙。所以走进一个不仅字母表不同、
they speak a different language,
but it was just so wildly different than anything that I ever saw.
And I will say I encountered, you know, real brutality.
There's a real brutality on the streets that at that time was sort of impossible.
It will find you one way or the other,
but also mixed with this unbelievable, just profound beauty
and this reverence for the arts.
You know, there's a statue on every corner of a,
说不同语言、而且和我见过的一切都截然不同的世界里。而且我必须说，我遭遇了真实的残酷。街头确实存在一种真实的残酷，在那个时候简直是不可避免的。它总会以某种方式找到你，但其中又交织着这种令人难以置信的、深刻的美丽以及对艺术的敬畏。你知道的，每个街角都有一尊剧作家、诗人或演员的雕像，
a playwright or a poet or an actor.
And honestly, at that time in my life,
you know, I don't know that I would have, you know,
responded, you know, really to American theater training.
You know, to be an actor in Russia was such a revered thing.
And it was a very, for lack of a better word,
it was a very masculine thing to do.
And do you think, John, sort of coming from your background then,
说实话，在我他人生的那个阶段，我不知道自己是否会对美国的戏剧训练做出那样的反应。在俄罗斯，成为一名演员是一件备受尊崇的事情。而且，用一个词来形容，这是一件非常具有男子气概的事情。你觉得，约翰，鉴于你当时的背景，
like, going to a place that had that, that was like,
it's almost like in your face arts in a way.
I mean, reverential and also like appreciation,
but so, you know, that it was so sort of startling in that way,
and it was so in your face,
do you think that that actually kind of woke you up to it in a way
that you might not have been appreciated here in America?
Do you know what I mean by that?
去到一个拥有这种氛围的地方——那种几乎是把艺术甩在你脸上的地方？我的意思是，既充满敬意又极具赏识，但又是如此（你知道的）令人震惊、如此直白——你觉得这真的在某种程度上唤醒了你吗？这种在当时的美国可能无法得到的赏识？你懂我的意思吗？
I do.
I mean, look, I think for me personally, and again, I know it sounds maybe, you know,
apologies, it sounds maybe grandiose,
but I really do feel like it saved my life.
I was getting in so much trouble,
and my life just was making no sense, and I just...
And it gave you structure.
It gave me structure, gave me something to believe in,
我懂。我是说，听着，我觉得就我个人而言，再次声明，我知道这听起来可能有点……抱歉，听起来可能有点宏大叙事，但我真的觉得它拯救了我的生命。我当时惹了太多麻烦，我的生活简直一团糟，我只是……它给了你结构。它给了我结构，给了我信仰的东西，
connected me with something spiritual.
And then when I went over there,
and my teachers were all folks
who kind of came up in a system
where public gathering was outlawed.
So for them to do plays,
they were doing plays in subway tunnels
and abandoned buildings.
将我与某种精神层面的东西连接起来。然后当我去了那里，我的老师们都是在那种“公众集会属于违法”的体制下成长起来的人。所以为了演戏，他们只能在地铁隧道和废弃的建筑物里演戏。
And had they been caught,
both the audience and the folks on stage
would have been sent away, sent to prison,
but it was so vital to them
that they had to do it anyway.
It was religious for them.
And so for my teachers to be those kinds of people,
You know, they're, you know, I mean...
如果被抓到，观众和台上的演员都会被流放、被关进监狱，但这对他们来说是如此重要，以至于他们无论如何都必须去做。这对他们来说就像宗教一样。所以，我的老师们就是这样的人，你知道的，我的意思是……
It makes me think, like, Sean, you're like,
Hey, any fun theater stories?
Like, yeah, I once got shot in the head
for doing a monologue.
Yeah, John, sometimes I'll ask people
who are in the theater on the show.
I'm like, do you have like a staple, hilarious,
like something gone wrong?
这让我想起，肖恩，你会说：“嘿，有什么有趣的戏剧故事吗？”就像“对，我曾经因为念独白而头部中弹。”对，约翰，有时候我会问节目里那些演戏剧的人。我会问：“你有没有什么标志性的、搞笑的、或者出了差错的故事？”
You ever forget your lines?
Yeah.
Like theater story, you know, like a classic,
something went wrong.
So, but I can't imagine, yeah.
Some of the words of Russia must be insane.
Wait, John, what was it?
I'm sorry, Jason, I just want to, we're in the theater here for a second, Jason, this is, because it involves you.
你有没有忘过词？对。就像戏剧故事一样，你知道的，比如经典的“出事故”的故事。但我无法想象，对。俄罗斯的一些经历一定疯狂透顶。等等，约翰，那是什么？对不起，杰森，我只是想……我们在剧场里聊一会儿，杰森，因为这涉及你。
You're on Broadway right now.
You're doing the show.
The show's over.
Do you have people come backstage?
Go ahead, Jason.
Jason has this.
Do you want people backstage when you're done with the show?
He's obsessed with the rules of people going backstage.
你现在在百老汇演戏。你在演出。演出结束了。后台会有人来找你吗？说吧，杰森。杰森有这个。演出结束后你想让别人去后台吗？他有后台强迫症，对谁能去后台有着严格的规矩。
Because I hear if you don't go back, you're being rude.
And I figure if you go back, you're being presumptuous that likes, you know, hey, you're famous, I'm famous.
We don't know each other, but you probably want to say hi, you know.
Oh, man.
How do you answer this without getting in trouble?
I don't know.
We've asked everybody, don't worry.
No, no, look, you know, it's such a weird thing
因为我听说如果你不去后台，就是不礼貌。而我想如果你去了后台，就会显得你很自大，就像是“嘿，你出名，我也出名。我们虽然不认识，但你可能想打个招呼吧”。哦，天哪。怎么回答这个问题才不会惹麻烦？我不知道。我们问过所有人了，别担心。不，不，听着，你知道的，这真的是一件很诡异的事，
because I don't want to know who's there,
and I feel like there's always a way
that the information kind of sneaks through.
I mean, Evan and I have done a thing.
There's a guest list.
So almost every night, Evan and I, you know,
I think last night we said Barack Obama was there
the night before.
因为我不想知道谁来了，而且我觉得总有办法让这些信息以某种方式走漏。我是说，埃文（Evan）和我做过一件事。有个嘉宾名单。所以几乎每天晚上，埃文和我，你知道的，我想昨晚我们说巴拉克·奥巴马（Barack Obama）在前一晚来看了。
I think we said, we always make shit up
just to make everybody out.
But I don't know.
You know, it's a very, I really appreciate when folks come back and it's not an awkward.
You know, it's really, it's really, it's like a hotbed of awkwardness, I feel like a lot of times.
Even when people are, they're clearly moved, it clearly was, but you know, you're so tired and you're in a weird sort of state.
Yeah, and that's just it.
You're kind of obligated to make them feel comfortable because it's your house, you know.
我想我们说过，我们总是胡编乱造来糊弄所有人。但我不知道。你知道的，这非常……当人们去后台而且不让人尴尬时，我真的很感激。你知道的，这真的，这真的就像一个充满尴尬情绪的温床，我感觉很多时候都是这样。甚至当人们明显被打动了、演出显然很棒的时候，但你知道的，你太累了，而且处于一种诡异的精神状态。对，就是这样。你有点被迫要让他们感到舒适，因为那是你的地盘，你知道的。
You're back there in your dress.
And they're obligated to make you feel.
feel that they loved it.
You know?
Right.
Jason, Jason, do you think that there's a world now?
Like next week, if you're in New York, you go and you see, which you should go see,
I want to come and see, Dog Day.
你在后台穿着戏服。而他们则被迫让你觉得他们很喜欢。你知道吗？对，杰森，杰森，你觉得现在有没有这样一种可能？比如下周如果你在纽约，你去看了——你应该去看看，我也想去看——《热天午后》。
I can't wait to see it?
Jason, can you now, having had this conversation with John, do you find that you could,
you could show up next week?
But only because we've had this conversation, so that when we see each other, it's not
going to be awkward and we'll give each other that little look.
Like, I would want you to do exactly what you want to do.
Like, if you wanted to come back, I would want you to come back.
but if you didn't, I would want you to feel so totally good about that.
我迫不及待想看了？杰森，既然你现在和约翰聊过了，你觉得你下周能去后台吗？但前提是我们聊过这个了，这样当我们见面时就不会尴尬，我们会给彼此那种眼神。比如，我希望你想做什么就做什么。如果你想去后台，我希望你来；
He's nerd.
He's just going out and enjoy your night, you know.
He's so nerd.
I just assume people want to get home, you know.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
John, do you do the, any kind of warm-up stuff with your voice?
I mean, do you even think about where you place your voice
但如果你不想去，我希望你完全没有心理负担。这书呆子。他只是想出去好好享受他的夜晚，你知道的。他太书呆子了。我只是假设人们想早点回家，你知道的。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。约翰，你做不做任何热身，比如跟嗓音有关的？我是说，你甚至会考虑你的声音放在哪个位置，
and how you support it so you can do eight shows a week and all that?
Because you do, if you don't know how to do it,
you do tend to, people tend to lose their voices pretty quickly.
Yeah, no, it's a, it's a, it's a, it's a,
a battle and and that that was the thing everybody said going in and i i i know sean you know it's so
well it's it's it's uh you know it's just it's like physically that that's one thing i sort of
feel like i always have in in in the bag you know like the physical thing you're not going to
exhaust me that way this is fucking exhausting i mean this is unlike anything i've ever done
以及如何发声支撑，这样你才能一周演八场以及做所有这些事吗？因为如果你不知道怎么做，你确实往往会……人们往往会很快失去嗓音。对，不，这是一个，一个，一个，一场战斗，而这也是每个人在开始时都会说的事，而且我知道肖恩，你太清楚了，这，这，这……你知道的，这就像在体力上，那是我觉得自己永远都能掌控的一方面，你知道的，比如体力方面，你是不会那样就把我累垮的。这他妈太累人了，我是说这和我做过的任何事都不同，
yeah but you know the um i you'll if you if you do see it you know i speak in a much higher
register when i when i do the show um and i think that that helps but yeah i
definitely warm up.
And, you know, Kate Wilson's working with us,
and she's incredible.
You know, she's like one of one.
I just did this show a few weeks ago called The Unknown.
And in it, every single night for seven shows a week,
对，但你知道的，呃，如果你，如果你去看了，你知道的，当我演出时，我用的是高得多的音域，呃，我猜这会有所帮助，但我的确会热身。而且，你知道的，凯特·威尔逊（Kate Wilson）在和我们合作，她太棒了。你知道的，她是独一无二的。我几周前刚演完一部叫《无名》（The Unknown）的剧。在剧里，每周七场的演出里，每天晚上，
the open, on page one, there's this stalker stalking me outside of the house.
And I would do the same movement every single time.
I would go up on the ball of my foot, right?
I would go on the ball of my foot looking like I'm looking for the stalker outside of the house.
Look at this.
No.
Oh, no.
I have a boot on.
开场的第一页，就有一个跟踪狂在房子外面跟踪我。而且我每次都会做同样的动作。我会用前脚掌着地，对吧？我会用前脚掌着地，表现得像是在寻找房子外面的跟踪狂。看这个。不。哦，不。我穿着靴子。
I have a boot on because of the play.
You didn't hear about boots?
Boots is...
Yeah, boots is back.
Because of this repetitive, right?
The repetitive movements that you do every single day.
So don't you...
Is any part of your body just like feeling that?
我因为这出戏穿着靴子。你没听说过靴子吗？靴子是……对，靴子又回来了。因为这种重复性的，对吧？你每天都在做的重复动作。所以难道你……你身体的某一部分没有那种感觉吗？
Any kind of like physical whatever?
Can I answer this for you, John?
You see, John doesn't mainline fucking ding-dongs.
Yeah, and tuna fish sandwiches.
He's not like acting like a person who needs to be cut out of their house.
You know what I mean?
His calf.
His calf can withstand a little press every month.
有没有任何身体上的什么……我可以替你回答吗，约翰？你看，约翰可不会把一堆他妈的叮咚蛋糕当主食。对，还有金枪鱼三明治。他可不会表现得像个需要把房子拆了才能出去的人。你知道我的意思吗？他的小腿。他的小腿完全经得起每个月的几下按压。
Yeah, because he's getting over 1,100 steps a day, okay?
I will say I try to box or go to the gym every day,
and I do think it really does help that you're doing something.
For Tracy and Sean, the gym is a thing.
It's spelled GYM.
Oh, okay, got it.
Now, Jim.
Hey, John, what was, without prying too much into your history
对，因为他一天要走1100多步呢，好吧？我必须说，我尽量每天都去拳击或去健身房，而且我确实觉得做点运动真的很有帮助。对特蕾西（Tracy）和肖恩来说，健身房是个地方。拼写是 G-Y-M。哦，好吧，明白了。现在，吉姆。嘿，约翰，在不过多打听你的历史和……
and your flavor of trouble that you like to get into?
What was it that you found about the theater that was a bit of...
Oh, Jay, I thought you were going to say, like,
what was your favorite kind of Coke?
Because I prefer Colombian.
Because I don't mind a speedy brand every once in a whatnot.
What was, like, what did you find theater did for you
that alleviated some of that, the cause?
你喜欢的麻烦类型的情况下，你觉得戏剧的什么魅力能稍微……哦，杰伊，我还以为你要问，比如你最喜欢哪种可卡因？因为我更喜欢哥伦比亚产的。因为我不介意偶尔来点提神的玩意儿。你觉得……你觉得戏剧为你做了什么，从而缓解了其中一些病因？
I found that the exact same energy that I tapped into when I was young and sort of my way of, you know, my best friends on the planet are still the guys that I grew up with.
They're my best friends.
And I think that we were wild kids.
And we, we, and I think our way of honestly telling each other that we loved each other was,
taking crazy risks together and doing things that we shouldn't have done.
And I felt that for me, the very same thing,
the reckless abandonment and the...
I'll say like the violence,
我发现，当我年轻时调动的正是那种完全相同的能量，那是我的一种方式，你知道的，我这辈子最好的朋友依然是我一起长大的那些家伙。他们是我最好的朋友。我想我们过去都是疯狂的小屁孩。而且我们，我们，我认为我们向彼此表达爱意的方式，老实说，就是一起去冒疯狂的风险，去做一些我们本不该做的事。我觉得对我来说，完全是同一回事，那种孤注一掷的放纵，还有……
the like let's just throw it all away.
Like whatever this is, we're fucking going.
Finding that, but using it, tapping into that same thing.
But it wasn't landing me in jail.
It wasn't landing me in trouble or getting kicked out of schools.
It was actually bringing joy to people
and making me find different parts of myself
that I knew how to sort of access really well,
我可以说就像暴力一样，就像“管他呢，我们他妈的上吧”。找到那种状态，但加以利用，调动同一种能量。但它没有把我送进监狱。它没有让我惹上麻烦或被学校开除。它实际上给人们带来了快乐，让我找到了自己身上那些我本就知道该如何很好地触及的不同部分，
but it was, I mean, again, without sounding like a cheese dick,
it was using it for good.
And it did, it saved my life.
Yeah.
I mentioned Walking Dead.
That was the first time that I feel like I remember seeing you
on a regular basis in something.
And I was like, I remember watching that show and thinking,
但它，我是说，再次声明，听起来不像是装模作样，它是把这种能量用在了正道上。而且确实，它拯救了我的生命。对。我提到了《行尸走肉》。那是让我觉得我第一次在某个作品里经常看到你的地方。我记得当时看那个剧时就在想，
who fuck is this dude?
He's so locked in.
so dialed like this dude is
he's got something was that
was that a thing was that a major turning point do you think
in your professional career
walking dead
yeah absolutely
这他妈是谁啊？他太专注了。状态太饱满了，这家伙身上有绝活。那是，那是真的吗？你觉得那是你职业生涯中的一个重大转折点吗，《行尸走肉》？对，绝对是的，
absolutely and and just in my life in general
at that point you know I got married
right after season one
to
to my wife who I met the day
I got home from Russia she's a
she was an ICU trauma nurse
we grew up together she's seen
绝对是的，而且对我的整个人生来说也是如此。当时，我在第一季结束后不久就结婚了，娶了我从俄罗斯回家的那天遇到的妻子，她曾是一名ICU创伤护理护士，我们一起长大，她见过
the worst of me
hopefully the
best of me.
But, you know, she's, she's my whole life.
And had my first child in the beginning of season two surrounded by people who had
young families, you know, doing this work.
And the work still meant so much to them.
And they were just family and work.
我最糟糕的一面，希望也有最好的一面。但是，你知道的，她是我生命的全部。我在第二季刚开始时有了第一个孩子，身边都是那些有年轻家庭、你知道的，在做这份工作的人。而且这份工作对他们来说依然意义重大。他们既是家庭又是工作。
And, but yeah, I think with Frank Deribont and that show, you know, it, none of us in a
million years thought it was going to be kind of the juggernaut thing that it was.
There was such humility to it.
and people believed in it so much.
And it's funny because if you put six or seven people out in the woods
and you say, okay, there's zombies out there,
if one person isn't going 100% towards that fucking truth,
it's like everything else is bullshit.
但是，是的，我觉得有了弗兰克·德拉邦特（Frank Darabont）和那部剧，我们做梦也没想到它会成为那种现象级的巨作。里面有一种极其谦逊的特质，
So the show was just such kind of total commitment right from the beginning.
And yeah, I was just so grateful to Frank
and so grateful to be a part of that show.
Yeah, it was definitely life-changing.
Yeah, I imagine.
It's funny you say that.
Yeah, like everybody's got to...
That show had such a great ability
人们对它深信不疑。这就很有趣，因为如果你把六七个人放在树林里，然后对他们说，“好吧，外面有僵尸”，如果其中一个人没有100%地投入到那种他妈的真实感中，那就全都是狗屁。所以那部剧从一开始就是那种全情投入的合作。是的，我非常感激弗兰克，也非常感激能成为那部剧的一部分。是的，这绝对是改变人生的一刻。对，我能想象。真有趣，你这么说。对啊，就像每个人都必须……那部剧有一种绝佳的能力，
to keep the tension
so taught at all times.
Like, you were just like always on the edge of your seat.
And you're right.
You imagine if you had one guy
just kind of dialing it in the frame.
Yeah, phoning it in.
You know what I mean?
能让紧张感在任何时刻都高度紧绷。就像，你总是看得提心吊胆的。你说得对。想象一下，如果里面有一个家伙在镜头前只是在敷衍了事。对，在混日子。你知道我的意思吗？
They're like, I think I doesn't see that worried
about what's going on.
Yeah, right.
Exactly.
Hey, John, what did...
Talk about the sort of that transition
from how acting sort of...
of serving you in one respect early on.
他们就像是，“我觉得这好像没那么让人担心”。对，没错。正解。嘿，约翰，关于……谈谈演员行业那种转变，早期它在某种程度上如何成就了你。
And then as sort of your demons,
you started to get some distance from your demons a bit.
And it's really starting to fall in love with the acting
and the talent you were recognizing in yourself.
And you started to shape some technique, I would imagine.
And talk about that transition into,
well, wait a second.
I'm no longer kind of that guy.
然后，随着你内心的恶魔逐渐远去，你开始摆脱内心的恶魔，你真的开始爱上表演以及你在自己身上发现的天赋。我想你开始形成某种表演技巧了。谈谈那种转变吧：“等等，我不再是那种人了。”
I'm kind of really becoming more this part of myself.
And this could actually become a,
career, an occupation, and I'm kind of decent at this. And, and, like, was there a point where you
realize, oh, wait, I'm kind of, I'm kind of all in on this now. And I don't really know how to do
anything else. And I like that. And this, this is going to be it. Let's, let's really become this guy.
And was there that moment? Or did it just kind of happen naturally as jobs kind of progressed? And
and now you look back and you go, wow, now I am this.
Well, look, I mean, I think that there's something,
“我真的越来越成为我自己的这部分了。这真的能成为一种职业、一种行当，而且我在这方面还算可以。”而且，有没有一个时刻让你意识到：“哦，等等，我这下真的是全力以赴了。而且我其实不会干别的了。我喜欢这样，这就是我的归宿了。让我们，让我们真正成为这样的人吧。”有没有过那样一个时刻？还是说，随着工作的推进，这一切就自然而然地发生了？以至于现在回过头来看，你会说：“哇，现在我就是这样的人了。”好吧，听着，我是说，我觉得有一种东西，
I don't know if you guys feel it being, you know,
with everything you guys have done and who you are,
but for me, I know the healthiest relationship
that I can have with this thing is to,
just to be hungry and to not really be at any place of arrival.
And what I love about it's the same thing.
thing I love about being a dad is that the only thing that's for certain is you're going to
fucking fail. You know, like, you're going to mess up and you got to like, you got to,
我不知道你们作为经历过这一切、有着诸多成就和身份的人是否能感同身受，但对我来说，我知道我与这个行当能建立的最健康的联系，就是保持饥饿感，永远不要觉得自己已经抵达了终点。而我热爱这一点的原因，和我身为父亲所热爱的东西是一样的——唯一确定的事情就是你他妈一定会失败。你知道的，你会搞砸，然后你必须去面对……
you got to own it and you, and you got to acknowledge it and you got to work through it.
And each one of those mess ups and each one of those failings is such an unbelievable opportunity
for connection and teaching and growing together for both you and your kid. And I feel so,
I feel like it's the exact same with what we do. And I'm, again, I'm just like,
very, very grateful that I get to do something that I can always just, I'm always chasing and trying
to get better at.
And I will say at the time, yeah, for sure.
And like right now, like, doing this play, like, to be this at this age and at this point
你必须坦然接受它，承认它，然后去克服它。每一次搞砸和每一次失败，对于你和你的孩子来说，都是一个绝佳的机会，能够以此建立连接、互相教育、共同成长。我觉得这和我们所做的事情完全一样。再次觉得，我能够做这样一件我一直在追赶、一直在努力做得更好的事情，我真的、真的非常感激。我想说，当时确实如此。就像现在这样，演这出戏，在这个年纪，在这个阶段
at my life can still be terrified.
It's such a thrill, you know?
It's dope.
Yeah, for sure.
It's very cool.
That's why you do it, yeah.
Yeah, but I will say for me, luckily, things started to kind of work out for me at the
exact same time that I started a family. And I will say it's just, for me, my life has become
我的人生仍然会感到害怕。这真是一种刺激，对吧？太棒了。对，没错。很酷。这就是你做这件事的原因，对吧。对，不过我想说，对我来说幸运的是，在我组建家庭的同时，事情开始逐渐好转了。我想说，对我来说，我的生活变得
really, really simple and clear. It's them and it's this. And I'm very happy with that.
That's not a coincidence, by the way. That's not a coincidence. I think we all know, like,
for me, I had the similar experiences. Having kids has cracked me open in a way that it's allowed
me to be open to all sorts of things. And so I always believe that those kinds of things go
hand in hand.
And, you know, it's funny.
You were saying this thing about, you know,
you're going to make mistakes.
非常、非常简单和清晰。只有他们和这个。对此我感到非常满意。顺便说一句，这不是巧合。这不是巧合。我想我们都知道，对我来说，我有过类似的经历。有了孩子以一种不可思议的方式打开了我的心扉，让我能够接纳各种各样的事情。所以我一直相信这些事情是密不可分的。你知道，这很有趣。你刚才说的那件事，你知道的，你会犯错。
And I always think about,
I remember watching this documentary
about this soccer team,
but the coach,
this very famous coach, Jose Marino.
We were talking to the team,
the team kind of got down on themselves,
and they were down at halftime.
我总是会想起，我记得看过一部关于某支足球队的纪录片，教练是一个非常著名的教练，何塞·穆里尼奥。我们在和球队谈话，队员们有点情绪低落，半场时落后了。
And it comes in,
they filmed his speech to the team,
and he was like,
you guys are acting like,
every time there's a mistake
or the other team gets a goal or whatever,
it's the end of the world.
And he's like,
他走进来，他们拍下了他对球队的演讲，他说，你们现在的表现就好像，每次有失误或者对方进球什么的，就好像世界末日一样。他说，
the other team is going to score.
Right.
You're going to make mistakes.
they're going to get a goal
because they're trying to do the same thing you are.
But the trick is,
what do you do?
How do you cope with it?
对方会进球的。没错。你们会犯错，他们会进球，因为他们在尝试做和你们一样的事情。但诀窍在于，你要怎么做？你如何应对？
That's the thing.
And I always stuck with me.
And I sort of apply it.
I don't know about you guys.
I think about that shit all the time in my life
when stuff doesn't go exactly my way.
I go, yeah, shit's not going to always go your way.
Okay.
就是这样。这件事一直刻在我心里。我一直在运用它。我不知道你们怎么样。当事情没有完全按我的意愿发展时，我脑子里总是想着这破事。我说，好吧，事情不可能总是如你所愿。好吧。
I can't fall apart when it doesn't.
I got to go, okay, now what?
What can I do now?
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And sometimes things go, you know, just the sort of proximity to, you know, real tragedy and real failure.
And, you know, these things, sometimes life hands you such a kick in the ass that will change your entire perspective.
But also, you know, there's real tragedy that I think comes part and parcel with it.
事情不顺时我不能崩溃。我得说，好吧，那接下来呢？我现在能做什么？你知道我的意思吗？是的。有时候事情的发展，你知道，仅仅是因为靠近了真正的悲剧和真正的失败。而且，你知道，生活有时会给你当头棒喝，彻底改变你的整个人生观。但同样地，你知道，伴随而来的还有真实的悲剧。
But sometimes you just get close to it.
Sometimes it's just a reawakening or you get close to something or you think maybe somebody's sick and they're not.
and and and and and I just
I feel like
it is it is so true
that with each
you know sort of failing or fall
or tragedy
但有时你只是离它很近。有时它只是一次重新觉醒，或者你离某些事情很近，或者你以为某人可能生病了其实并没有。而且……我只是觉得，每一次失败、跌倒或悲剧，都是如此真实……
there offers such an opportunity
and I do think
you know primarily
the job is now to
to be a parent
and you got to hold it together
and you got to show them
the different lenses that
都提供了这样一个机会，我也确实认为，你知道，现在的主要工作就是做一个父母，你必须稳住自己，你必须向他们展示不同的视角，
you know that
that that just changing your perspective
how much can be gained by that
I'm able to luckily I'm able to show my kids
a lot of failure, so it's good.
There you. I'm very open with them.
Me too. How old are the kids, John?
I have a 14-year-old, a 12-year-old, a 10-year-old,
你知道，只要改变你的视角，就能从中收获多少。我很幸运能向我的孩子们展示很多失败，所以这挺好的。给你。我对他们很坦诚。我也是。孩子们多大了，约翰？我有一个14岁的，一个12岁的，一个10岁的，
and then my little four-year-old niece has come to live with us the last few years, too.
Oh, wow.
Are any of them showing any interest in what you do?
Oh, gosh, no, man.
No, no, no.
I mean, I might...
Have they come to see the play?
Yeah, they've come to see the play, and they're coming again this weekend,
然后我四岁的小侄女这几年也来和我们一起生活。哦，哇。他们当中有人对你做的事情表现出兴趣吗？哦，天哪，没有，伙计。没有，没有。我是说，我可能会……他们来看过这出戏吗？对，他们来看过这出戏，这周末还要来看，
but my kids are all, you know, they're very into sports,
and the outdoors and, you know, and it's, you know,
they have very full and beautiful hearts, each one of them.
And each one of them is so, you know, such an individual.
You know, it's there for them, I think, if they'd ever want it.
But I think right now, what I do is not too cool to them.
How do you, because I think about this for myself with you,
I've got two girls, 19 and 14.
但我的孩子们，你知道，他们非常喜欢运动和户外活动，而且，你知道，他们每个人都拥有非常充实而美好的心灵。他们每个人都是如此独特的一个个体。你知道，如果他们想要的话，我认为这个机会一直都在那里。但我现在觉得，我做的事情对他们来说不够酷。你是怎么看待的，因为我为自己想过这些，我有两个女儿，19岁和14岁。
And, you know, I haven't had a perfectly straight line towards where I'm at, you know, emotionally or otherwise.
You know, I didn't do, you know, the perfect thing all the time.
But I like where I've landed.
And I don't think I would have landed in this spot had I not banged into a couple of walls.
And so as I see my girls growing up and, you know, when, you know,
when they go through things that are not sheltered,
I start to think, well, how would I react if they make a wrong choice?
You know, and because, like, I don't want to be hypocritical.
而且，你知道，我走到今天这一步，并不是一条笔直的线，无论是在情感上还是其他方面。你知道，我并没有总是做出完美的举动。但我喜欢我现在的落脚点。而且我认为，如果不是撞了几次南墙，我绝不会走到今天这个位置。所以当我看着女儿们长大，当她们经历那些没有被过度保护的事情时，我在想，如果她们做出错误的决定，我会作何反应？你知道，因为我不希望自己显得虚伪。
I like the way my adversity has sort of shaped me.
And so I battle with that as a parent.
You know, you want your kids to have a pristine, you know, travel.
So how, you know, like, I'm sure your kids are, they've got half.
By pristine, do you mean, like, protected?
Like, you want them to?
Well, no.
but I mean, I think it's just a natural instinct.
我喜欢逆境对我的塑造。所以我作为父母也在与这种心态作斗争。你知道，你希望你的孩子们拥有一段完美的旅程。那么，你知道，我确信你的孩子们，他们有一半……完美的旅程，你的意思是受到保护吗？就像你想让他们……嗯，不是。但我的意思是，我认为这是一种本能。
You don't want your kid to ever make a mistake.
You don't want anything to yet.
Right.
So I just, I wonder if my kids ever started to experiment with some of the risks that I went through,
I wouldn't want to be, I wouldn't encourage them to do that,
but I certainly wouldn't be unaccepting of them coming to me afterwards and saying,
yeah, I screwed up, I did this.
You know, so I'm not sure what the question is, but, you know, I guess would you,
你永远不希望你的孩子犯错。你不想让他们经历任何挫折。对吧。所以我在想，如果我的孩子们开始尝试我曾经经历过的一些风险，我不会希望他们这么做，但我绝对不会排斥他们在事后跑来对我说：“爸，我搞砸了，我做了这个。”所以，我不知道问题是什么，但我想你会……
how tolerant would you be if your kids started to walk?
locked down somewhere the same path you did knowing that you came out okay you know yeah i mean it's such a good
look i mean it's it's it's it's again it's like these are the questions where we're you know you know as
parents it's like you know we're it's such a blessing to be this obsessed with these people's lives
and their well-being and i think adversity is such a important word there's absolutely no way that i could
do the things that i could do put food on the table the way that i do if i didn't get the the the licks that i got
and the bumps that I got
and was in the valleys that I spent a lot of time in.
如果你的孩子开始走上你曾经走过的同一条老路，你会抱有多大程度的宽容？明知你最后结果还不错。你知道，是的，我的意思是，这真的很有看头。我的意思是，这又是那种作为父母的问题，你知道，我们……能对这些人的生活和福祉如此着迷，这真是一种福气。我认为逆境是一个非常重要的词。绝对没有可能，如果我没有挨过那些生活给我的耳光、受过那些磕磕绊绊、没有在那些我度过了很长时间的低谷里待过，我今天就无法做我能做的事，无法像现在这样把食物端上餐桌。
And so I knew, you know, instinctively,
I know with my children,
adversity is so necessary.
And how do I teach my kids the things I've learned
but also know they cannot learn them
the way that I learned them
because there was so many times
and I'm sure it's the same for you guys
所以我凭直觉就知道，对于我的孩子们来说，逆境是如此必要。我该如何教导孩子们我所学到的东西，同时又知道他们无法像我那样去经历和学习，因为有太多次了——我相信你们也是这样——
where this shit could have gone either way.
It was razor-fucking close.
And like, you know,
and we've lost people.
I've lost people.
I've lost my freedom.
I've been in situations where, okay, by the grace of whatever you want to call it,
it just went a different way.
这些破事随时可能走向任何一个极端。真的是千钧一发。就像，你知道，我们失去了身边的人。我也失去过人。我失去过自由。我经历过这样的情况：谢天谢地，不论你把它归功于什么，事情最终走向了另一个方向。
But, oh my gosh, like, I've seen it really not work out.
And so, you know, from a young age with my kids, you know, they were, you know,
competing in martial arts.
They were, you know, like, everybody needs to know how to swim.
Everybody needs to know how to defend themselves.
Everybody needs to know how to be in the outdoors.
And how can you sort of under the umbrella of safety,
put them in really, really hard, challenging situations
但是，天哪，我见过它真正搞砸的时候。所以，你知道，从小到大对我的孩子们，他们在武术比赛中竞争，每个人都需要学会游泳，每个人都需要学会保护自己，每个人都需要学会在户外生存。你如何能在安全的庇护伞下，把他们置于真正艰难、充满挑战的境地中，
where they can learn from.
And I think moreover, I think especially for my boys,
you know, how do I teach them, you know,
in this day and age where there's so few role models out there
for these young boys, how do I teach them that, like, yes,
like it is absolutely paramount that you are a protector,
that you're a provider, that you're somebody that can be counted on,
that people in a crowd, if something goes wrong,
让他们从中学习？而且我认为更重要的是，特别是对我的男孩们来说，在这个缺乏榜样的时代，我该如何教导他们：是的，成为一个保护者、一个经济支柱、一个值得信赖的人，当人群中发生意外时，你们拥有提供帮助的知识和能力，这绝对是至关重要的；
will you guys have the know-how
and the ability to be helpful?
But also, equally important,
are you sensitive, are you kind,
are you vulnerable, are you open, are you curious?
Do you not judge?
Do you, are you hungry for conversation?
Are you hungry to learn?
但同样重要的是：你是否敏感、是否善良、是否愿意展露脆弱、是否思想开放、是否充满好奇心？你是否不加评判？你是否渴望交流？你是否渴望学习？
Are you hungry to be challenged by somebody
who thinks, looks, feels,
praise to somebody completely different than you?
Are you confident enough in yourself
to approach any conversation,
but also be,
nimble enough to listen and to be swayed and to be changed.
I'm not, John, I need your guidance.
你是否渴望去接受那些想法、外表、感受以及信仰与你完全不同的人的挑战？你在面对任何对话时是否都足够自信，同时也足够灵活去倾听、去被说服、去改变？我……不，约翰，我需要你的指导。
Jesus Christ.
Come on, man.
But, you know, it's all of it.
You know, like, that's what's so cool about it.
And I do feel, I don't know if you guys feel the same thing,
but I do feel these paths for me are really lining up,
where the work that, at least the work that I want to be doing,
you know, really has a, it really informs this.
天呐。拜托，老兄。但是，你知道，这正是全部的意义所在。你知道，这才是最酷的地方。而且我确实觉得，我不知道你们是否有同感，但我确实觉得我人生的这些道路正在真正合拢，我所做的工作——至少是我想要做的工作——确实对这一切产生了深远的影响。
It informs me as a human being.
I get a deeper understanding.
but also, you know, one day my kids will look at it and they'll say,
one, yeah, dad was working his ass off,
but two, you know, that there's a, that there's a message there,
that there's a humanity there that they see in all people,
even when you play a monster, you know,
that there's a little kid in there, there's a scared little kid in there,
它塑造了我作为一个人的本质。我获得了更深刻的理解。但同时，你知道，总有一天我的孩子们会看到这一点，他们会说：第一，爸爸工作非常拼命；第二，你知道，这里面传达着一种信息，他们能在所有人身上看到一种人性，即使你扮演的是一个怪物，你知道，里面其实藏着一个小男孩，里面藏着一个害怕的小男孩，
and that it's never too late.
It's never too late to bring somebody out of the valley.
How in the world did you gather all this wisdom?
Everything you just said,
seriously, it's incredible.
Sean, he doesn't spend all this time
watching below deck eating Swedish fish.
You know what I mean?
而且永远不会太迟。把一个人从低谷中拉出来，永远都不会太迟。你到底是怎么收集到这么多人生智慧的？你刚才说的每一句话，说真的，太不可思议了。肖恩，他可不会把所有时间都用来看着《下层甲板》吃瑞典鱼软糖。你知道我的意思吗？
I got to cross that off my list.
I mean, what are you doing?
What are you talking about?
He's out of the world, okay?
No, traitors.
Traders.
No, seriously, you're just, that was just incredible.
我得把这个从我的清单上划掉。我是说，你在干什么？你在说什么？他太与世隔绝了，好吧？不，反叛者。反叛者。反叛者。不，说真的，你刚才说的真的太不可思议了。
Everything you just said, I was like rapture.
He went through the fire.
I know, but Sean, you, I mean, look, you,
everybody that I know here on this thing,
Sean, you, you, you came, you didn't have,
nobody handed you this.
This is true.
You came from a, you know, you had a single mom household.
你刚才说的每一句话，我都听得入迷了。他历经了烈火的考验。我知道，但是肖恩，你，我是说，听着，你，这里我认识的每一个人，肖恩，你，你，你走过来时，你没有……没有人把这一切直接端到你面前。这倒是真的。你来自一个……你知道，你是在单亲家庭长大的。
Your dad left, which we make fun of all the time.
It's super funny the way he left.
It was so sudden.
Fantastic.
And five kids just left them all.
Just one day, just gone.
Just evaporated.
Just tire screech.
你父亲离开了，我们经常拿这个开玩笑。他离开的方式太搞笑了。太突然了。太绝了。五个孩子，直接把他们全抛下了。有一天，就这么消失了。直接蒸发了。伴随着轮胎摩擦地面的声音。
Yeah, just like he was on the, like on the USS Enterprise.
He just got beamed out of there.
So, so.
But I mean, Sean, you grew up in that, and you had to kind of
fend for yourself and you fend your way
and you were a talented dude and J.B., you were
out in the world working since you were a kid
and you had to kind of fend for yourself as well.
对，就像他在联邦星舰进取号上一样。他直接被传送走了。所以……但是肖恩，你在那样的环境中长大，你必须靠自己摸索出路，你是一个很有才华的家伙。而JB，你从小就在社会上打拼，你也必须靠自己谋生。
Like, you know what it's like, and none of us
knew anybody. I didn't know anybody in show business.
And Will? You had like, how many
maids and servers did you have to leave your house?
We ended up reducing
after the crash of 87, we reduced
a little bit. But
at boarding school, everybody was, anyway,
就像，你知道那是什么滋味，我们谁也不认识什么人。我在演艺圈里谁也不认识。还有威尔？你家得有多少个女佣和侍者要辞退啊？87年股灾之后我们稍微裁减了一些。但在寄宿学校里，大家都是，总之，
doesn't matter. Parking spot for all of them.
You know, it's like...
But the point is, like, you
I bet you have more,
it feels like John,
what's nice is you have real access
to your experience
in a way that's very,
无所谓了。给他们每个人留个停车位。你知道，就像……但重点是，我觉得约翰最棒的地方在于，你有能力真正触及自己的经历，
that you stay very in touch with it,
and that's great because you can kind of,
because your kids can learn from that.
And that is a thing that I try to do.
I try to, Jason, like you were saying,
I have those moments where I'm like,
trying to understand their experience,
where they are, trying to identify with where they're at,
你与自己的过去保持着非常紧密的联系，这太棒了，因为你可以……因为你的孩子们可以从中学习。这也是我一直尝试去做的事情。我试着去，杰森，就像你刚才说的，我也有过那些时刻，我试着去理解他们的经历，理解他们所在的处境，试着去体会他们现在的感受，
where I was at that age.
I have three boys.
I have two teenagers,
age boys, and I spent a lot of time going, you know, they're going through it.
They're going through those years.
And I go, like, let them have the thing.
And also don't make it about me and like, hey, when I was a kid, just let them have
those things.
也就是我当年那个年纪的感受。我有三个男孩。我有两个正处于青春期的男孩，我花了很多时间去想，你知道的，他们正在经历这些。他们正在经历那些岁月。我在想，就让他们去经历吧。同时不要把这变成我自己的事，不要说“嘿，我像你这么大的时候……”，而是让他们自己去经历那些事。
But try to identify with those moments.
And it's not always easy, you know, but you try to do it as much as you can.
Yeah.
We'll be right back.
Back to the show.
John, do you have, because everything, I could talk to you about all this stuff.
You were just talking about forever.
I love talking about that.
但要试着去理解那些时刻。这并不总是容易的，你知道，但你只要尽你所能去尝试。好的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。约翰，你有没有……因为所有这些，我可以和你聊这些事情聊到永远。我太喜欢聊这个了。
John, do not get your dog.
He's going to try to go side chat.
No, now, do your kids feel like dad is overwhelming
with all of those kind of teachings and kind of parenting,
or do they actually listen to what you're saying?
I'm not sure.
You know, I'm not sure.
约翰，别管你的狗了。它要试图去聊私密话题了。它要试图去聊私密话题了。不，现在说正事，你的孩子们觉得爸爸有那么多的教导和育儿经，会不会让他们觉得喘不过气来？还是说他们真的会听你的话？我不太确定。你知道，我不太确定。
You know, like my oldest son, boxes, I'm his trainer.
I coach my, you know, I coach them in football,
and I've coached them in basketball since they were young.
You know, I coach my daughter.
The thing that I know they see is what I saw in my dad.
And, you know, my dad was the guy that when people in the neighborhood,
people around D.C., my friends, they all had their own relationships with my dad.
When they were in trouble, they went to my dad.
你知道，就像我的大儿子练拳击，我是他的教练。我训练我的，你知道，我训练他们踢足球，他们还小的时候我就教他们打篮球。你知道，我还训练我女儿。我深知他们能看到的是什么，那是我在我父亲身上看到的东西。你知道，我父亲就是那种人在社区里、在华盛顿特区周围、我的朋友们，他们每个人都和我的父亲有着各自的联系。当他们遇到麻烦时，他们会去找我父亲。
He was their coach.
He was a guy that he'd call him straight.
You know, he wouldn't bullshit them.
He'd help them.
He always had everybody's back.
And he wouldn't.
judge. Let's
work through this. Let's get through this
他是他们的教练。他是那种有话直说的人。你知道，他不会对他们胡说八道。他会帮助他们。他总是罩着所有人。而且他不会评判。我们一起来解决这个问题。让我们度过难关，
and then we'll deal with the judgment and all that
shit later. But he was a guy that
could really be depended on. And so I
think my kids have
seen that, you know, I have real relationships.
You know, we live in, you know, this small
town of, you know, we live in Ohio
and we've been there 15 years. I love Ohio.
然后我们再来处理评判和那些破事。但他真的是一个可以依靠的人。所以我认为我的孩子们看到了这一点，你知道，我有真正的亲密关系。你知道，我们住在一个小镇里，你知道，我们住在俄亥俄州，在那里住了15年了。我爱俄亥俄。
And it's such a small, yeah, it's beautiful.
And it's a beautiful community
where you still can,
you know, raise other kids. You know, you parent
other people's kids. You know,
kids come to me and you know i i i teach them how to box i've i've been coaching football there for the last
six years and and and i you know we have a theater there where the kids come and and so i think that
the one thing my kids know is that it's not i'm i'm i'm sort of the same with all of them and
那是一个很小的，是的，很美。那是一个美丽的社区，在那里你依然可以，你知道，去抚养别人的孩子。你知道，你会参与管教别人的孩子。孩子们会来找我，你知道，我教他们打拳击，我在那里当了六年橄榄球教练，而且，你知道，我们在那里有一个剧院，孩子们会来这里。所以我觉得我的孩子们知道的一件事是，我对待他们所有人都是一样的。
if kid comes to me it doesn't matter if he's my kid or your kid you know i i really really
i want to give them whatever i can give them with with while saying look i don't have the
fucking answers like i hit every wall you can hit right but like it's never too
too late and let your parents love you,
whether you're, whether they left
or not, whether they're incarcerated or not, they love
so. Sean, by the way, he started, he started
a theater, basically like a theater and a
如果一个孩子来找我，不管他是我的孩子还是你的孩子，你知道，我真的、真的很想倾其所有去帮助他们，同时对他们说：“听着，我他妈的也没有答案，我踩过你可能踩过的每一颗雷，但是——永远都不会太迟，让你的父母去爱你们吧，不管他们有没有离开，不管他们有没有坐牢，他们都是爱你的。”顺便说一句，肖恩，他在俄亥俄州创办了一个剧院，基本上就像是一个剧院和一个
theater festival in up in Ohio. Is that right,
John? Oh, I didn't, I didn't know that. Yeah.
That's cool. Yeah, I mean, it's just
you know, in the town, it's, it's,
the town has given me so much
and I love it and, and, um,
you know, since we,
since my first exposure to
剧院节。是这样吗，约翰？哦，我不知道，我不知道这事。太酷了。是的，我是说，你知道，在那个小镇里，小镇给予了我太多，我热爱这里。而且，自从我们……自从我第一次接触到
it, um, you know, I
saw something in the young people in that
town, you know, 10, 15 years ago where there was such sturdiness and such grace and kindness.
There's a, it's yes, it's yes, sir, no ma'am, but there's nothing repressed or suppressed.
The kids are curious.
There's a really strong onus of the young people in Ohio to get out, go see the world,
go experience things, and then come back and raise your family there.
And it's a really beautiful community.
这里，你知道，10到15年前，我在那个小镇的年轻人身上看到了一些特质，那种坚韧、优雅和善良。那里的人会说“好的，先生”、“不用了，女士”，但没有任何被压抑或克制的东西。孩子们充满好奇心。俄亥俄州的年轻人有一种非常强烈的责任感，那就是走出去，看世界，去体验，然后回到家乡组建家庭。这真的是一个非常美好的社区。
But I will say over the past, you know, five, ten years, especially, so many folks,
have moved up there.
And culturally, it's really a place in conflict
because the tipping point has kind of happens.
You know, we see it in big cities all the time.
Definitely happened in D.C. where I grew up.
But, you know, in Ohio, it's really gotten to a place
where, you know, the public school there,
但我得说，在过去这五十年里，尤其是现在，有这么多人都搬到这里来了。在文化上，这里确实成了一个充满冲突的地方，因为临界点已经发生了。你知道我们在大城市里经常看到这种情况。我长大的华盛顿特区绝对发生过。但是，你知道，在俄亥俄州，情况真的到了这样一个地步：那里的公立学校——
which was a real bastion of public education,
has really suffered because of the influx of Angelinos
that have come up there.
And so I just, I love that school.
I love these kids.
I love these institutional Ohio families.
So we built a theater in an old, defunct school building.
And all the proceeds go to the public school theater department.
它曾经是公立教育真正的堡垒——由于大批从洛杉矶涌入的人的到来，现在真的受到了很大的冲击。所以我只是……我热爱那所学校。我热爱这些孩子。我热爱这些俄亥俄州的传统家庭。所以我们在一个废弃的老学校建筑里建了一座剧院。所有的收益都捐给了公立学校的戏剧部门。
And, you know, we were able to raise, yeah, a ton of it was really cool.
Sean's agreeing to do a show there next year.
It's great.
Yeah, that's great.
What an agreement.
What a way to agree to something.
You know, Will always makes fun of me because I, whenever I go to, like, a party or a dinner, I want to leave right away.
And I'm like, I learned it from my dad.
而且，你知道，我们筹集到了，是的，一大笔钱，这真的很酷。肖恩已经答应明年去那里演一场演出。太棒了。是的，太棒了。这答应得真爽快。答应别人事情还能这样。你知道，威尔总是取笑我，因为每当我参加派对或晚宴时，我都想立刻离开。我就想：我是从我爸那里学来的。
Oh, look at that.
Look who jumped on.
You did teach you something.
You mentioned, you mentioned D.C. in Maryland, and I want to get to because it was one of the, I, for me, it was a show that really, I thought like, wow, it really fucking just blew me away.
When you played, was it, Wayne Jenkins?
Yeah, yeah.
And we owned the city.
哦，看那个。看看谁跳进来了。看看谁跳进来了。他确实教了你一些东西。你提到过，你提到了华盛顿特区和马里兰州，我想谈谈这个，因为这是一个，对我和我的感受来说，是一部真的让我觉得“哇，这太他妈震撼了”的剧。当你扮演的是，是韦恩·詹金斯吗？对，对。《我们拥有这座城市》。
Do you guys see that on HBO, this David Simon show?
It's unbelievable.
And what's cool is.
Now, kind of just talking to you, I can see that, like, you brought some of your own knowledge of all that kind of stuff and, like, sort of the guys who ended up staying on the wrong track or got on the wrong track and never got off in this really, I mean, Wayne is a very compromised character, right?
And he does, and I think that somewhere along the line, when he started, he thinks he's doing the right thing, right?
Like, he thinks he's fighting in this, but he actually ends up sort of going rogue or bad or whatever.
but he sees himself not as doing that.
Anyway, it's a very complex portrayal,
你们在HBO看过大卫·西蒙这部剧吗？太不可思议了。而且最酷的是。现在，跟你聊了这些，我能看出，你把你自己对这类事情的一些见解带进来了，比如那些最终误入歧途、上了贼船就再也没有回头的家伙们。韦恩是一个非常妥协的角色，对吧？他做的事，而且我认为在某种程度上，当他开始时，他认为自己在做正确的事，对吧？就像他觉得自己是在进行这场战斗，但实际上他最终却变得无法无天或者变坏了，诸如此类。但他并不觉得自己是在那样做。无论如何，这是一个非常复杂的刻画，
and I love that show.
I mean, that must tell me about working with David Simon
and what that experience was like.
It's excellent, man.
Thanks, man.
I appreciate it.
That one is my heart.
And, you know, it was such a thrill and an honor for me.
我太喜欢那部剧了。我是说，这一定……跟我聊聊和David Simon合作以及那段经历是怎样的。太棒了，老兄。谢谢你，老兄。我很感激。那部剧是我的心头好。而且，你知道，对我来说这是一种巨大的刺激和荣誉。
I think first and foremost, you know, at that time,
in the wake of Freddie Gray and in the midst of George Floyd
and everything that was going on in this country.
and for me just being so, I think naturally,
based on people in my life and based on my own experience,
I'm so revolted by the flag waving in this country,
the people on either side of the polls just waving their flag full of rhetoric,
but they've never been in the valleys.
我想首先也是最重要的，你知道，在那个时期，在弗雷迪·格雷事件之后，在乔治·弗洛伊德事件以及这个国家正在发生的一切的阴影下。对我来说，我自然而然地——基于我生命中的人和我自己的经历——对这个国家到处挥舞旗帜的行为感到无比反感，两极的人们都在挥舞着充满空洞言辞的旗帜，但他们从来没有真正去过低谷。
They've never been in the situation where they're actually rubbing elbows
with the other side.
So you can't, there's no access to recognizing decency in each other.
There's no access for empathy.
there's no access to for friendship or for any level of understanding
because you're just staying on your mountaintop
you know, from the, you know, just waving your flag.
And so for me to go into this project, you know,
他们从未处于那种真正与对立面擦肩而过的境地。所以你无法……没有机会去认出彼此身上的体面。没有同理心的渠道。没有建立友谊或任何层面理解的渠道，因为你只是站在你的山顶上，你知道，从那上面（挥舞着旗帜）。所以对我来说，加入这个项目，你知道，
that, you know, in Baltimore,
which is sort of like right in the tip of the spear
of race and policing at that time.
Yeah.
You know, and get this front row ticket
and also just to have the access coming in
sort of with the street cred of David Simon
and how much the wire, you know,
在巴尔的摩，那可以说是当时种族和警民冲突的最前沿。是的。你知道，能够拿到这张第一排的门票，而且因为带着大卫·西蒙的街头声誉以及《火线》这部剧的影响力，你知道，
you know, in that city, that wire for both the guys on the street,
the people in the community, and for the police,
like that is, that is, like, required watching.
Like, the cops that I know in Baltimore,
they watch that every year to remind them that it's not personal, it's business.
You guys got to see it.
Yeah, I would love to.
You've seen the wire, right?
你知道，在那座城市里，《火线》这部剧对于街头的小混混、社区居民以及警察来说，那就是——那是必看之作。就像我在巴尔的摩认识的警察，他们每年都会看这部剧，来提醒自己这不是个人恩怨，这是公事。你们俩得去看看。是的，我很想看。你们看过《火线》，对吧？
You guys have seen the wire, right?
Yeah, not yet.
Yeah, yeah.
So for me to kind of go in there like that, you know, I got to go,
you know, I rode out with those guys every night for three straight months
and went on SWAT raids with the county.
SWAT team and the city SWAT team, but got to know Wayne, got to know that whole unit of the
GunTrace Task Force. So I made unbelievable friends and I was able to see, you know, I was just so
你们都看过《火线》，对吧？对，还没呢。对，对。所以对我来说，以那种方式切入进去，你知道，我必须去……我连续三个月每天晚上都跟那些家伙一起出警，跟县特警队和市特警队一起参加突袭行动，但我也借此了解了韦恩，了解了枪支追踪特遣队的整个部门。所以我结交了难以置信的朋友，我也能够看到，你知道，我真的非常……
grateful to really see it in that way. But I think more than anything else, man. And, you know,
look, he was considered, you know, the most corrupt, the most vicious, the most sort of vile,
you know, police officer in the history of that city. So to go into the police department and say,
hey, I want to ride out with you guys,
I want to be around you guys to research this,
this very, very ugly chapter of their life.
I learned quickly, you know, with policing,
you know, how,
非常感激能以那种方式亲眼见证这一切。但我认为最重要的是，伙计。而且，你知道，听着，他被认为是那座城市历史上最腐败、最凶残、最卑劣的警察。所以能够走进警察局说：“嘿，我想和你们一起出警，我想和你们待在一起，来研究他们生命中这个非常非常丑陋的章节。”我很快了解到，你知道，在警务工作中，除了那些被腐败警务彻底毁灭的受害者和社区之外，
other than the victims and the community
that are just drastically devastated by corrupt policing,
it's also good cops are just,
are terrorized by it,
and their careers are completely destroyed by it.
And their safety on the street is totally upended by it as well.
But I think most,
Mostly, you know, for me, the key for me was how do you play this guy and not just play him as a monster?
好警察其实也同样深受其害，他们的职业生涯被彻底毁掉。他们在街头的人身安全也被完全颠覆了。但我认为最重要的是，对我来说，关键在于：你如何去扮演这个家伙，而不把他仅仅演成一个怪物？
How do you find, you know, some sort of, and it was interesting, man, because every single person who knew Wayne, it was the first thing I said to him when I first met him, everybody who talked to him said, you know, even if he was in the middle of robbing a drug dealer or, you know, shaking a guy down, making a false arrest, no matter what it was, if any of his kids needed him,
at any point, if there was ever an issue with the kids,
he would run home immediately.
And it really hit me, you know,
how can you engage in such corruption,
knowing that most likely this is going to have a bad end
because criminality almost always ends bad?
How can you be that attuned to your family?
你如何在其中找到某种……而且这很有趣，伙计，因为认识韦恩的每个人——这是我第一次见到他时对他说的话——每个谈论他的人都说，即使他正在抢劫毒贩、或者敲诈勒索某人、进行虚假逮捕，不管是什么情况，只要他的任何一个孩子在任何时候需要他，只要孩子们出了任何问题，他都会立刻跑回家里。这真的触动了我，你知道，一个人怎么能一边参与如此深重的腐败，明知这很可能会有一个糟糕的结局（因为犯罪活动几乎总是以悲剧收场），一边又对家庭如此上心？
And you're really doing one to support your family
because you feel like you're not getting paid what you deserve.
But that sort of conundrum and dichotomy, you know,
really was at the crux of who I think he is
and why he was so kind of torn apart.
But he wasn't just a monster.
Right, right, right.
Well, yeah, no, he's complied.
你这么做其实有一部分是为了养家糊口，因为你觉得自己的薪水配不上你的付出。但那种困惑和二分法，确实构成了我认为他是谁的核心，也是他为什么如此分裂的原因。但他不只是个怪物。对，对，对。好吧，是的，不，他很配合。
Sean has, you had a little bit of criminality.
Remember that time you guys almost got a ticket?
Scotty Devil Park while you ran into Chipotle.
I remember that story.
That was risky.
Wait, but when I was in college, I stole a turkey sandwich from a 7-Eleven.
And I got arrested.
Are you going to play the turkey sandwich in the movie?
肖恩，你以前也有过一点点犯罪记录。还记得那次你们差点吃罚单吗？你跑去奇波雷（Chipotle）买卷饼时把车停在斯科蒂魔鬼停车场。我还记得那个故事。太冒险了。等等，我上大学时，曾从7-Eleven偷过一个火鸡三明治。然后我被捕了。你打算在电影里演那个火鸡三明治吗？
You get died with David Simon director.
David Simon.
Hey, John, John.
I'll read for it.
John, you're such a great communicator.
That's sick, yeah.
It's unbelievable.
You're such a great communicator,
你跟导演大卫·西蒙死磕到底了。大卫·西蒙。嘿，约翰，约翰。我可以去试镜。约翰，你太会表达了。太牛了，真的。这太不可思议了。你太会表达了，
and you have such a passion for community and country,
and it seems like you do not shy away from opportunities for leadership.
Have you ever thought about politics at all?
Do you see that ever?
I mean, no, I know.
No, no, I think everybody has that reaction
anytime anybody ever thinks about it or it's mentioned them.
But you look at our, I'm not asking,
你对社区和国家有着如此强烈的热情，看起来你从不避讳展现领导才能。你有没有考虑过从政？你觉得以后会有这种可能吗？我是说，没有，我知道。不，不，我想任何人只要一想到这个或者别人对他们提起，都会有这种本能的反应。但你看看我们的……我不是在问，
I don't care what side of the political spectrum you're on,
but you look at our current leaders, our current...
Like, you yearn for someone that can communicate like you
and that can have the kind of genuine passion for people,
for condition and community.
And we need folks like you if you ever have the time.
So you got my vote.
Yeah.
我不在乎你属于政治光谱的哪一边，但你看看我们当前的领导人，我们当前的……你会渴望有这样一个人，能够像你一样表达，能够对人民、对社会状况和社区有着那种真诚的热情。如果你什么时候有空的话，我们需要像你这样的人。所以你有一票。对。
I've, oh, jeez, I don't.
Be careful, but I, look, no, I mean, I, look, I, I, I appreciate that.
I think the people that know me well, my brothers, I've, I've a brother who's a cancer surgeon
the head of oncology at UCLA in orthopedics.
He's like, wow.
That guy should be running for, that guy is, yeah, but, but, but, but, you know, I really believe
that what we do can really be effective.
I, I just do in my heart.
我有……哦，天哪，我没有。小心点，但是，听着，不，我是说，我很感激。我觉得那些真正了解我的人，我的兄弟们……我有一个哥哥是癌症外科医生，是加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）骨科的肿瘤科主任。他就像是，哇。那家伙应该去竞选……那家伙是……是的，但是，但是，但是，你知道，我真的相信我们所做的事情可以产生真正的影响。我发自内心地这么认为。
And I think that, you know, for me, I feel most natural and most authentic,
honestly, coaching and teaching and doing it in my community on the one-on-one.
Yeah.
You know, and I think as far, I do really feel that what we do can really provide a service
and can create real change and can really, you know, bring human beings together.
And that's what I really want to do.
Yeah, and you do it as well as you can.
而且我认为，对我来说，说实话，我觉得最自然、最真实的方式就是在社区里一对一地进行执教和教学。是的。是的。你知道，而且我认为，就目前而言，我真的觉得我们所做的事情可以提供真正的服务，可以创造真正的改变，并且能够真正地把人类凝聚在一起。这正是我真正想做的事。是的，你已经尽可能好地完成了。
Yeah.
And he does it, like I said, like in We Own the City,
like it is a great lesson in a lot of sort of really complex issues in that way.
So it's you are, you are being of service while, like through your art.
Yeah, he makes smiles.
And then, I mean, dude, you got so many cool things.
He's not getting votes, he's getting smiles.
You've got so many cool things come.
是的。而且他做到了，就像我说的，就像在《我们拥有这座城市》里一样，这是对许多真正复杂的问题的一个极好的诠释。所以，你是在通过你的艺术来为大家服务。是的，他收获了微笑。然后，我是说，老兄，你身上有太多酷炫的东西了。他收获的不是选票，是微笑。你身上有太多酷炫的事要发生了。
You've done so many cool things.
And it's like you're like accelerating, man.
Like you're just like, it's awesome.
And I'm so psyched that everybody's getting to see you work in so many different ways.
You've got this summer you've got the new Spider-Man,
brand new days coming out
with, right, with the Punisher in it
and that trailer like broke every record
你做过那么多酷炫的事。而且感觉就像你在加速一样，老兄。就像是……太棒了。我太高兴大家能看到你在各个方面展现演技了。今年夏天你还有新的《蜘蛛侠》，全新的时代即将来临，里面还有惩罚者，那个预告片一出来，
when it came out. That trailer was so sick.
Yeah, like that. And I'm not like a huge
superhero movie fan and even
I'm like, fuck, this movie looks dope.
And then you're in The Odyssey, right? And Chris Nolan's The Odyssey.
Nice. Can you talk a little bit about working with that? Because obviously
Chris Nolan's one of the greats. Yeah, look at...
I had to slug it out there with that fucking drip, Matt Damon.
就打破了所有的记录。那个预告片太带劲了。对，就是那种。而且我不是那种超级英雄电影的超级粉丝，连我都觉得：操，这电影看起来太赞了。然后你还要演《奥德赛》，对吧？克里斯托弗·诺兰的《奥德赛》。太棒了。你能聊聊和（诺兰）合作的感受吗？因为显然克里斯托弗·诺兰是大师级人物。是的，你看……我得和那个该死的累赘马特·达蒙一起在片场拼命苦干。
Oh, God. Yeah. I got that. Sorry.
We talk about a squeaky wheel.
Yeah, that's time.
What a complainer.
You made it, you made it, though.
Complainer.
He's a terrible guy.
Look, I think with Chris, you know, it's like, I think with, you know, I think with, you know, I think you get to see sometimes people doing, like, exactly what they're put on this earth to do.
哦，天哪。是的。我懂了。抱歉。说到一个讨嫌的家伙。对，就是这样。真是个爱抱怨的人。不过，你还是成功了。爱抱怨。他是个糟糕的家伙。听着，我觉得和克里斯合作，你知道，就好像，我觉得，你知道，有时候你能看到人们在做……就像是他们被派到这个世界上来注定要完成的事情。
And that's how I feel about Nolan.
I mean, I think there's these stories, again, you know, everybody kind of going in, oh, you have no idea how hard it's going to be and how rigorous.
how, you know, there's no, and for me, I'm like, let's fucking, like, I love that.
It's music to my ears.
There's nobody who's working harder on that set than he is.
And the directors that I've gotten to work with, you know, like, Deni, you know, Scorsese or Polansky or, you know, Derek.
I mean, there's so many of them, you know, they're all so enormously different.
But the thing that I feel like is uniform among all the greats for me, I don't know if you guys feel this way.
这就是我对诺兰的看法。我的意思是，我觉得这些故事，再次说明，每个人进去之前都会想：“哦，你根本不知道这有多难，多严格，多……”而且，你知道，根本没有……对我来说，我就会想：“操，我喜欢这样。”这简直是天籁之音。那个剧组里没有任何人比他更努力地工作了。我合作过的那些导演，你知道，比如丹尼斯，你知道，斯科塞斯、波兰斯基，或者德里克。我是说，有那么多导演，你知道，他们每个人都极其不同。但我觉得所有伟大导演共同具备的一个特点，我不知道你们是否有同感，
But, you know, they've done so much work.
They know it so intimately well.
But there's really an atmosphere of exploration and freedom once you get to work.
And I find no bigger sort of telltale sign of mediocrity than people who it has to be a certain way.
And I couldn't believe that within this unbelievable structure and this unbelievable understanding of exactly what he wanted, you know, he's still both.
inspired and not just allowed but demanded, you know, real freedom and creativity within
every moment.
Like, yeah, do you find yourself, like, working with him and, like, and these huge pieces
那就是，他们做了大量的功课。他们对作品的理解极其深刻。但是一旦开始工作，现场就会有一种充满探索和自由的氛围。我发现平庸最明显的标志，莫过于那些必须墨守成规的人。我简直不敢相信，在这样一种令人难以置信的架构中，在对他想要的东西有着如此透彻理解的同时，他不仅能够做到兼具灵感，而且不仅允许，甚至在每一刻都强力要求真正的自由和创造力。就像，是的，你发现自己在和他的合作中，以及在你所做的这些宏大作品里……我的意思是，为了上帝的见证，这是《奥德赛》。里面是不是也有这样一种精神：嘿，让我们去发掘它？绝对的。绝对的。而且，你知道，我认为在这些电影中，你知道，我几年前拍过一部电影叫《怒火特攻队》，我还拍了《太平洋战争》，那有点像《兄弟连》的续作。你知道，有时这些电影里有一群男人，你们都在
that you're doing?
I mean, it's the Odyssey for Christ's sake.
And is it, and within that, there's like a spirit of like, hey, let's find it.
Like, I, I, absolutely.
Absolutely.
And, you know, I think in these films, you know, I, you know, I did this movie Fury some
years back and I did the Pacific, which was sort of the next in the band of brothers.
And, you know, there's these movies sometimes where there's a group of guys and you're all
为了一个目标并肩作战，一起经历艰难险阻，你们会建立起那种不可思议的羁绊。你知道，在这部电影里有一群男人，他们是奥德修斯的船员，是马特·达蒙的手下。就是这群演员。你知道，他们在八个不同的国家度过了八个月。工作极其努力。而且，你知道，
just sort of like slogging it out together for the thing and you forge these unbelievable
relationships. You know, and there's a group of men in this movie that, you know,
were Odysseus's men, were Matt Damon's men. And it was this group of actors. You know,
they did eight months in like eight different countries. Worked so incredibly hard. And, you know,
And, you know, what was cool is, you know, I was only on the movie for a couple months.
And but I got to really be a part of that group for the time that I was there.
And that was such a blessing for me.
I think that, you know, the best thing that this offers this life is the people that you meet along the way and the relationships that you get.
你知道，最酷的是，你知道，我在电影里只待了几个月。但我在那里的那段时间里，真正成为了那个集体的一部分。这对我来说真是一种莫大的福气。我认为，人生能提供的最好的东西，就是一路上遇到的人和建立起来的羁绊。
That's what you're going to die with.
And I was so honored to be a part of that group of Odysseus' men and that I felt just a taste of what, you know, the real long.
long, hard slog the adventure was.
And, you know, that's my big tape.
That's what I'm most grateful for.
That's great.
And then I mentioned, yeah,
and then you, and then Spider-Man with Tom Holland,
这些才是你临终时能带走的东西。我非常荣幸能成为奥德修斯手下那些船员中的一员，我也只尝到了那种漫长、艰难、充满冒险的征程究竟是何滋味。这就是我最大的收获。这也是我最感激的。太棒了。然后我提到了，是的，然后你，还有和汤姆·霍兰德合作的《蜘蛛侠》，
the great Tom Holland.
I love Tom.
I mean, look, you know, like I got to,
you know, I have a Punisher special that I wrote
that's coming out next week that I'm really excited about.
And then I'm also doing the Punisher in Spider-Man.
And, you know, with Tom,
because Tom was in the Odyssey as well
伟大的汤姆·霍兰德。我太喜欢汤姆了。我是说，听着，你知道，我有幸……我写了一部《惩罚者》特别篇，下周就要上映了，我对此感到非常兴奋。然后我还在《蜘蛛侠》里饰演惩罚者。而且，你知道，因为汤姆也参演了《奥德赛》，
I've known Tom since he was 17
who did a movie in Ireland together
I made his Spider-Man audition tape
and he made my Punisher audition tape
No way!
And I gotta tell you man
this fucking kid when he was 17 years old
and everyone was auditioning for Spider-Man
我从汤姆17岁时就认识他了，我们在爱尔兰一起拍过一部电影。我帮他录了《蜘蛛侠》的试镜带，他帮我录了《惩罚者》的试镜带。不会吧！我得告诉你，伙计，这个该死的小孩在17岁的时候，当每个人都在为《蜘蛛侠》试镜时，
this dude he was like I'm gonna get
like I am Spider-Man and I was like
look dude mathematically I just gotta be honest
like I don't know
but like he had such
unbelievable conviction and belief
and he's so fucking talented
but beyond all of it like there is not
这家伙就说：“我要拿下这个角色——我就是蜘蛛侠。”而我说：“听着，老兄，从数学概率上讲，我得诚实地说，我不知道……但他有那种令人难以置信的信念感和自信，而且他太他妈有才华了。但抛开这一切不谈，
there is not a better guy
like he was raised so well
I love his family
I love his his better half
I'm so proud of
the man and the movie star
and the human ambassador
that he's become
真的没有……没有比他更好的人了。他被教导得太好了。我爱他的家人，我爱他的另一半。我为他成长为现在的这个男人、电影明星以及人类大使感到无比骄傲。
I love his relationship he's really in love
they really have a great thing I love them
and it's so
cool for me, you know, now, you know, whatever it is, 10 years later to come back. And,
you know, I spent the whole, you know, we did two movies back to back with each other. And I love
this guy. And I couldn't be happier for him. Oh, that's so good. Dude, well, we, we couldn't be
happier for you, man. I mean, you're just such a, you're so great. And like J.B. was saying,
you're such a great communicator. It's just awesome to listen to you talking about stuff.
我喜欢他的感情生活，他是真的陷入了爱河，他们真的很棒，我太喜欢他们了。对我来说，你知道的，现在，不管怎样，10年后能再回来，这真的很酷。而且，你知道的，我花了一整段，你知道的，我们俩连续拍了两部电影。我太喜欢这家伙了。我为他感到由衷的高兴。哦，太棒了。老兄，我们，我们为也你感到由衷的高兴，伙计。我的意思是，你真的是个，你太棒了。就像JB刚才说的，你是个极佳的沟通者。听你聊这些事情简直太享受了。
I'm so happy to have met you here. I know, man. You're just, cool. You're just sick. And, and
Thanks, guys.
You've got so much going on.
You've got Spider-Man.
Brand New Day comes July 31st.
You've got The Odyssey opens June 17th.
And, of course, Dog Day afternoon on Broadway.
So congratulations.
很高兴能在这里见到你。我懂，老兄。你真的很酷。你太牛了。谢谢你们，伙计们。你们有太多项目在进行了。你有《蜘蛛侠：崭新的一天》，7月31日上映。你有《奥德赛》，6.17开幕。当然，还有百老汇的《热天午后》。所以恭喜你。
It's just such a joy, yeah.
John, see if you can find a work ethic before we see you again.
I was going to ask you for a theater story,
but next time I would love to hear just a tragic theater story.
I have tons of them.
Me too.
They always make me laugh really hard.
Well, we're going to see you backstage.
这真是一大乐事，是的。约翰，看看我们下次见你之前你能找到一点职业道德吗。我本来想向你讨个剧场故事的，但下次我很想听一个悲惨的剧场故事。我有成堆的故事。我也是。它们总能让我笑得前仰后合。好吧，我们会在后台见你的。
I'm going to drag Jason backstage and we're going to come back.
Come on, guys.
Get your ass out here, Willie, and drag me out of this apartment.
I'm going to come in a couple weeks.
Let's go see it.
The great John Berthel.
John, thanks for joining us, dude.
It's such an honor, guys.
我要把杰森拉到后台，然后我们会回来的。来吧，伙计们。把你们的屁股挪出来，威利，把我从这个公寓里拉出去。我几周后会来的。我们去看看吧。伟大的约翰·博瑟尔。约翰，谢谢你加入我们，老兄。这真是个荣幸，伙计们。
Thank you so much.
I appreciate you guys.
Nice to meet you, buddy.
See you soon.
See you, dude.
Have a wonderful night.
Thanks for having me, guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
非常感谢。我很感激你们。很高兴认识你，兄弟。回头见。再见，老兄。祝你们度过美妙的夜晚。谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。对，对，对。
Bye, buddy.
Bye-bye.
This guy.
Yeah.
I mean, you know what I find.
But he was great, Will.
I think I'm going to put them, I'm going to put them on the list with Alicia Keys, Lionel Richie, John Bernthal.
For your, for favorites.
再见，兄弟。拜拜。这家伙。对。我的意思是，你知道我发现了什么。但他太棒了，威尔。我想我要把他，我要把他列入和艾莉西亚·凯斯、莱昂内尔·里奇、乔·博恩瑟一样的名单里。作为你的，最喜欢的嘉宾。
My three favorite guests.
Yep.
He's, I agree, man.
He's unbelievable.
Or I should say instead of not favorite guests, favorite interviews, right?
So we don't offend some of the people that are my, you know, some of my favorite people.
Amongst your favorites.
Amongst my favorites.
我最喜欢的三个嘉宾。是的。他，我同意，老兄。他太不可思议了。或者我应该说，不是最喜欢的嘉宾，是最喜欢的采访对象，对吧？这样我们就不会冒犯到某些人，你知道的，我最喜欢的一些人。在你最喜欢的人之中。在我最喜欢的人之中。
Thank you.
Yeah.
You know, though, to be, and I really mean this, and this goes for you guys, too, I think you have to be.
No, I think you, no, it's a big compliment.
I think you have to be super, super, super fucking smart like he is and like both of you are, to be talented, to be that talented.
I don't know that dummies are talented.
I've met a couple, but true, you're right.
谢谢。是的。你知道吗，为了，我是认真的，这对你们也是一样的，我认为你必须是。不，我认为你，不，这是个巨大的赞美。我认为你必须超级、超级、超级他妈的聪明，就像他一样，也像你们两个一样，才能有才华，才能有那样的才华。我不知道笨蛋有没有才华。我遇到过几个，但确实，你是对的。
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah, without the, yeah, yeah, but I mean, there's all kinds of different talent, though, too, right?
I mean, you know, I think it's clear that he's drawing on his checkered past
when he's playing these incredibly complex characters
and tapping into stuff he knows.
J.B. And Sean, please, go watch We Own This Cities on HBO.
Yeah, for sure.
You're in New York for the next little while.
你知道我的意思吗？是的，没有，是的，是的，但我的意思是，也有各种不同类型的才华，对吧？我的意思是，你知道，我认为很明显，他在扮演这些极其复杂的角色时，借鉴了他那丰富多彩的过去，并挖掘了他所熟悉的东西。JB和肖恩，请去HBO看《我们拥有这座城市》。是的，肯定的。你接下来一段时间都在纽约。
You've got time at night.
Watch it an episode of night.
It's not very...
It's so good.
I've found it his portrayal to be astonishing.
Like, it's really something.
I love that.
And, you know, all the stuff that he's doing in Ohio, which is, you know, there's a neighboring town just outside of it.
你晚上有时间。一晚看一集。它不是非常……太精彩了。我发现他的表演令人震惊。真的非常了不起。我太喜欢这个了。而且，你知道的，他在俄亥俄州所做的一切，你知道的，那附近有一个邻近的镇子。
Well, when you walk in, it's oh hi, and then when you leave, it's, oh, bye.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjave, and Bennett Barbico.
Smart.
LAMS.
好吧，当你走进去时，是“哦，嗨”（Ohio），当你离开时，是“哦，拜”（Oh, bye）。Smartless由Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjave和Bennett Barbico100%有机手工打造。Smartless。